Okay, I am really excited. About? I've got some great news. About? Well, it's about today. Oh, what's happening today? We are... Well, fuck, you're going to find out.
好吧，我很兴奋。关于什么？我有些好消息。关于什么？嗯，是关于今天的。哦，今天有什么安排？我们是……好吧，操，你们马上就会知道了。
It's an all new Smartless. Smart. We are... well fuck you're gonna find out it's an all-new smartlis. That was you guys. Hi. We just had a little connection problem with Will. It sounded like you were Hal from 2001. I'm glad you got it all worked out. I know, me too. Was there a ghost in the machine?
全新一期的SmartLess。太棒了。我们是……好吧，操，你们马上就会知道了，这是全新一期的SmartLess。那是你们。嗨。我们刚刚和威尔的连线出了点小问题。听起来你就像《2001太空漫游》里的哈尔。很高兴你们都弄好了。我知道，我也是。机器里有鬼吗？
I guess so. Right? Isn't that a band? That was an album the police did. It was by the police. Very good album. By the way, the police, you know, I used to listen to them all the time. We don't hear about them in, you know.
我猜是吧。对吧？那不是个乐队吗？那是警察乐队（The Police）出的一张专辑。是警察乐队的。非常棒的一张专辑。顺便说一句，警察乐队，你知道的，我以前经常听他们的歌。我们现在不太能听到他们的消息了，你知道的。
Well, cause Sting went off on his own. I know, but it's just a good memory. When he went on his own, is it accurate to say that he defunded the police? Wow. I don't know, it's early. It's early. It's really early. Is it accurate to say that he defunded the police? Wow. I don't know, it's early. It's early. It's really early.
好吧，因为斯汀单飞了。我知道，但这只是个美好的回忆。他单飞的时候，说他“削减了警察的经费”（defunded the police）准确吗？哇。我不知道，这还很早。还很早。真的还很早。说他削减了警察的经费准确吗？哇。我不知道，这还很早。还很早。真的还很早。
It's early, what am I gonna do? They're not all gonna be home runs, J.B. Jason, so did we miss you on Sunday because you just weren't feeling it or were you out of town? No, I was flying back to work. I left at noon. Oh, that's right.
还很早，我能怎么办？又不是每次都能击出全垒打，J.B.、杰森，所以我们周日错过你是因你感觉不对劲还是你不在城里？不，我当时在飞回工作的路上。我中午离开的。哦，对哦。
I thought Amanda said that. Apropos of nothing, Shaunie, I was sent a picture from you and Eric Idol in a picture together. It looked like it might have been a bowling alley, you guys were in? That was a roller rink. Okay, so I was close. That was just yesterday.
我以为阿曼达是这么说的。扯远了，肖妮，我收到一张你和埃里克·埃德尔（Eric Idle）的合影。那看起来好像是个保龄球馆，你们在那儿？那是家轮滑场。好吧，那我猜得差不多。那就在昨天。
Pretty close. And that was just sort of just like a date you guys had, like maybe meet me at the roller skating rink? Tell me what you look like so I can recognize you? First of all, that's crazy. I wonder who sent you that. Was it Kevin Nealon? Eric, Idle, and I share an attorney,
差不得多。那感觉就像是你们俩的一次约会，比如“在轮滑场见吧”？“告诉我你长什么样好让我认出你”？首先，这太疯狂了。我想知道是谁把那个发给你的。是凯文·尼龙（Kevin Nealon）吗？埃里克·埃德尔和我共用一个律师，
the great Tom Hoverman. Oh, okay, great. Yeah, no, it was Kevin Nealon's wife, Susan Yagley, who's a very funny actress person. She decided to have her birthday party at a roller derby, like a rolling, what is that called? Roller rink. It's a roller skating rink?
伟大的汤姆·霍弗曼。哦，好吧，太棒了。对，不是，那是凯文·尼龙的妻子苏珊·亚格利（Susan Yagley），她是一个非常搞笑的女演员。她决定在旱冰场举办她的生日派对，就像一个轮滑，那叫什么来着？轮滑场。是个轮滑溜冰场？
Roller skating rink, yeah. And so I was too nervous. Have you been drinking this morning? You feel like you've been. No, it's too early. He's got a latte going. Have you been eating? No, not at all.
轮滑溜冰场，对。然后我太紧张了。你今天早上喝酒了吗？你感觉好像喝了。不，还太早。他正在喝拿铁。你吃东西了吗？没有，完全没有。
You haven't eaten anything yet? And so Scotty, I No, not at all. You haven't eaten anything yet? And so Scotty, I was really nervous. No, I haven't eaten anything. So Scotty, I was really nervous. So I didn't- Scotty's frying up some donut holes. But they did have like pizza and cake. Thank God.
你什么都没吃吗？所以斯科蒂，我——没有，完全没有。你什么都没吃吗？所以斯科蒂，我真的很紧张。不，我什么都没吃。所以斯科蒂，我真的很紧张。所以我没有——斯科蒂正在炸一些甜甜圈洞。但他们确实有披萨和蛋糕。谢天谢地。
And all that, and popcorn. I described Sean the other day as junk food curious. Hey, were there any terrible accidents there at the roller skating rink? Yeah, because you really, really hurt your tailbone. Oh, do you have any good roller skate rink accident stories? Can't wait to ask the guest. Yes, so Scotty, so I didn't want to put them on
还有那些，以及爆米花。前几天我形容肖恩对垃圾食品充满好奇。嘿，旱冰场里有什么可怕的事故吗？有啊，因为你真的把尾椎骨狠狠地撞伤了。哦，你有什么精彩的旱冰场事故故事吗？等不及要问嘉宾了。对，所以斯科蒂，所以我不想穿上
because I'm on blood thinners. I'm almost done with my blood thinners because of my AFib, right, it's long. Hang on, what does a roller skating accident have to do with blood thinners? Because if you hit your head or something, you could bleed like, right, aphid line. Hang on, what does a roller skating accident have to do with blood donation? Because if you hit your head or something, you could bleed like, you could bleed out and die. Way to think about the worst case scenario.
因为我在吃抗凝血剂。我快吃完抗凝血剂了，因为我的房颤，对，这说来话长。等等，旱冰场事故和抗凝血剂有什么关系？因为如果你撞到头什么的，你可能会流血，对吧，蚜虫线（译者注：此处威尔口误或播客转录错误）。等等，旱冰场事故和献血有什么关系？因为如果你撞到头什么的，你可能会流血，你可能会失血过多而死。真会往最坏的情况想。
So anyway, so the first 30 seconds, my friend Kevin, who you've both met, Kevin and Kerry, Kevin, bam, mashed his head on the fucking wood floor, wiped out immediately. And so I ran over to him, I was like, are you all right, you all right? He's like, yeah, no, I go, are you seeing stars? And he's like, no, which meant yes.
所以不管怎样，刚开始的前30秒，我的朋友凯文——你们俩都见过，凯文和克里——凯文，“砰”的一声，脑袋狠狠地砸在尼玛的木地板上，当场就趴下了。所以我跑过去看他，我说，你没事吧，你没事吧？他说，没事，不，我说，你看到星星了吗？他说，没有，这意味着看到了。
When did they get here? That's a bummer if he looked at you and he says he's not seeing any stars. I mean, that's insult to his injury's insult to his injury, you know? God, Will, you really, I'm glad you rebooted. Yeah, somebody slept really well. Yeah, I did sleep well. Anyway, roller derby, but good idea for a birthday party, right?
他们是什么时候来的？如果他看着你说他没看到星星，那真是太惨了。我是说，这简直是在他的伤口上撒盐，你知道吗？天哪，威尔，我真高兴你重启了。对，有人睡得真香。对，我确实睡得很好。不管怎样，轮滑，但作为生日派对是个好主意，对吧？
For an adult. Sounds like not a good idea. It's up there with an ice skating rink. You've just described why it's not a good idea. No, Kevin's totally fine. Oh, good. But I walked, because I didn't want to put the skates on, so Scotty had skates on, and I walked with him around You've just described why it's not a good idea. No, Kevin's totally fine. Oh good. Izzy. But I walked,
对成年人来说。听起来不是个好主意。它和溜冰场不相上下。你刚才已经解释了为什么这不是个好主意。不，凯文完全没事。哦，太好了。但我走着，因为我不想穿上冰鞋，所以斯科蒂穿了冰鞋，我陪着他在场地周围散步——你刚才已经解释了为什么这不是个好主意。不，凯文完全没事。哦，太好了。伊兹。但我走着，
because I didn't want to put the skates on, so Scotty had skates on, and I walked with him around the thing while he skated. And that's so dumb. A little bit. It's kind of on brand. You know, now they've got at these rinks, you know, like an old man, old woman walker
因为我不想穿上冰鞋，所以斯科蒂穿了冰鞋，我陪着他在场地周围散步。这太蠢了。有点蠢。挺符合他的一贯作风。你知道，现在这些溜冰场里都有那种老人用的助行器，
that can help you ice skate or roller skate. They didn't have that in my day. You just yes I see that the kids had that yeah yeah yeah but but so Eric Idol was there I never met Eric Idol from Monty Python I was like oh my god what a genius yeah really nice guy did he did he ask for like a drink from you or is he like hey can I get a diet coke? Just bring my car up, boy. Yeah, he was really nice. Whose guest is it today? It's my guest. And how do you feel about your choice today, Will?
可以帮你滑冰或轮滑。我那个年代可没有。你只要——对，我看到孩子们有那个。对，对，但——但是埃里克·埃德尔在那儿，我以前从未见过蒙提·派森（Monty Python）的埃里克·埃德尔，我当时想，天哪，真是个天才。对，非常好的人。他——他跟你要过什么饮料吗，还是说，嘿，能给我来杯健怡可乐吗？“把我的车开过来，小子。”对，他人真的很好。今天是哪个的嘉宾？是我的嘉宾。那你对你今天的选择感觉如何，威尔？
I feel really, really good. Really? Yeah, you know why? You know what I like? I like international superstars. Oh my gosh. A lot. This is a legit, you don't often.
我感觉真的，真的很好。真的吗？对，你知道为什么吗？你知道我喜欢什么吗？我喜欢国际巨星。哦天哪。很多。这是一个名副其实的，你可不常。
Are we gonna see stars? Are we gonna see stars today? You're gonna see a major international superstar and I'm embarrassing him, but it's so true. But on top of it, or sort of not on top of it, beneath it, he's a really, really, really great guy that I've had the good fortune of spending a little bit of time with over the years.
我们会看到星星吗？我们今天会看到星星吗？你会看到一位重磅国际巨星，虽然我在让他难为情，但这千真万确。但除此之外，或者说差不多，在这一切之下，他是一个真的、真的、真的非常好的人，我有幸在过去几年里和他共度了一小段时间。
Super, super good dude. And then you forget that he sold a good jillion records. I mean, a good jillion records over the years as a member of a rock and roll Hall of Fame band. And then as an equally impressive solo career, he's in the Songwriters Hall of Fame. He has written multiple massive hits, and he's an actor and he's an incredible philanthropist and he's got a new docu-series about his story. I think it's called Thank You, Goodnight. Yeah, guys, once I start getting, if I start saying specific things you're just
超级、超级好的人。然后你都忘了他是卖出了数不清的唱片。我是说，作为摇滚名人堂乐队的成员，这些年来他卖出了数不清的唱片。随后是同样令人印象深刻的个人音乐生涯，他进入了词曲作者名人堂。他写过无数首大热金曲，他是一名演员，他是一位不可思议的慈善家，他还有一个关于他故事的新纪录片系列。我想它叫《谢谢你，晚安》。对，伙计们，一旦我开始，如果我开始说具体的事情，你们就会
gonna guess it so I'm just gonna guys, please allow me to introduce you to the one, the only, the phenomenal, Mr. John Bon Jovi. Wow! It's triple A list. Look, I mean, it is triple, triple. No one sings higher. Yeah. Or better.
直接猜出来，所以我打算——伙计们，请容许我向大家介绍独一无二、绝无仅有、现象级的——约翰·邦·乔维（John Bon Jovi）先生！哇！这是AAA级大咖。看，我是说，这绝对是顶级的。没人能唱得更高了。对。或者更好。
Or better. Or better. Oh my gosh, good morning. I saw John like six months ago or something last summer and I was like, would you ever consider doing our podcast? And he said yes, and it took a minute to organize. He's a very busy man. And I'm so happy you're here.
或者更好。或者更好。哦天哪，早上好。我大约六个月前或去年夏天某个时候见过约翰，当时我就想，你会不会考虑上我们的播客？他说好，花了一点时间才安排好。他是个非常忙的人。我很高兴你今天能来。
John, good to see you, man. I'm so happy to be here. I'm a huge fan. I listen all the time and I watch the entire series that you guys did on the road. Oh my God. In the dead of winter. Yes, it was great.
约翰，很高兴见到你，老兄。我也很高兴能来。我是你的超级粉丝。我经常听，而且我把你们拍的那部公路系列纪录片全看完了。哦天哪。在严冬腊月里。是的，太棒了。
It was great. Listener, we have John Bon Jovi from the White House. You look like you're in the kind of place I would love to live. You're doing well, clearly, right? This is a nice, there's clothing. I see a lot of house envy just in the pre-roll when you were talking about Sean's house.
太棒了。听众朋友们，我们请来了来自白宫的约翰·邦·乔维。你看上去住在一个我非常想住的地方。你显然过得不错，对吧？这是一个好地方，有衣服。当你们刚才在片头讨论肖恩的房子时，我就看出有很多对房子的羡慕嫉妒恨。
Well, look at me, I'm doing a hostage video here. Oh, it's good. I need to up my situation. But no, and I see a Patriots jersey. Are you a Patriots fan? Oh yeah, look it, I see the background in my office. Yes, I'm a huge Patriots fan. That is Bill Belichick's hoodie.
好吧，看看我，我在这儿拍人质视频呢。哦，这挺好。我得提高一下我的居住环境了。不过没有，我看到了一件爱国者队的球衣。你是爱国者队的球迷吗？哦，是的，你看，我办公室的背景里。是的，我是爱国者队的超级粉丝。那是比尔·贝利奇克（Bill Belichick）的连帽衫。
Now, oh my God, they're wearing the short sleeve. Why did he wear a short-sleeved hoodie? Fashion statement, right? Yeah. Fashion, well, no, he also, he might run hot. Like, he wants the thing, but he also runs a little bit hot. My question is, who cuts them? Do you know, John, who cuts them?
现在，哦天哪，他们穿着短袖。他为什么穿短袖连帽衫？时尚宣言，对吧？对。时尚，嗯，不，他可能也比较怕热。就像，他想要那件衣服，但他也确实有点容易发热。我的问题是，谁剪的？你知道吗，约翰，是谁剪的？
I don't know who cuts them. No, knowing that when you look closely, I think he probably, I think he cuts him with a butter knife. Yeah. Well that, and just has an odd, he's got sweaty forearms, and I've never met anyone with that. Maybe Thoreau came over and gave him the snip.
我不知道是谁剪的。不，如果你仔细看的话，我猜他可能是用黄油刀剪的。对。除了那个，还有点奇怪，他的前臂爱出汗，我从没见过这样的人。也许梭罗（Thoreau）过来帮他剪的。
It might be a Justin. Yeah, maybe. He's giving Justin Thoreau a run for his money. Well, listen, I think if you're winning that many championships, you know, you're doing something right, and he doesn't want to mess with whatever system he's got going.
可能是贾斯廷（Justin）。对，也许吧。他让贾斯廷·塞洛克斯（Justin Theroux）都自叹弗如了。好吧，听着，我觉得如果你赢了那么多冠军，你知道的，你一定做对了什么，而且他不想去打乱他现有的任何体系。
Yeah. Why do you have director's chairs there? Just to hang out in? any championships, you know, you're doing something right and he doesn't want to mess with whatever system he's got going. Yeah. Why do you have director's chairs there? Just to hang out in? Because I'm a groupie and when I did my little movie career, I actually stole the entire chair, not the back. You guys that make real movies, I took the whole chair. You took the whole chair.
对。你为什么在那儿放导演椅？只是为了坐着闲晃吗？赢了那么多冠军，你知道的，你一定做对了什么，而且他不想去打乱他现有的任何体系。对。你为什么在那儿放导演椅？只是为了坐着闲晃吗？因为我是个追星族，当我拍我那部小电影生涯的作品时，我实际上把整把椅子都偷了，不是靠背。你们这些拍真电影的人，我把整把椅子都拿走了。你把整把椅子都拿走了。
Well, you made a bunch of movies. I want to get into that in a minute. You've done a lot, actually quite a surprising amount of acting. Yeah, it's a fascinating career. Yeah, I think that, but you started as a singer, as a musician, and I kinda wanna talk about, what was that?
好吧，你拍过一堆电影。我一会儿想深入聊聊这个。你拍过很多，实际上数量惊人的演艺作品。对，这是一段迷人的职业生涯。对，我认为，但你最初是以歌手、音乐人的身份出道的，我有点想聊聊，那是什么？
I wanna know how you know you could sing. Well, yeah, like what was that first thing, growing up in New Jersey, what was that early music scene, and how did you plug into it? You know, how do you get started? Yeah. What do you do? Any kid that's all of our ages
我想知道你是怎么发现自己会唱歌的。好吧，对，就像第一次那样，在新泽西长大，早期的音乐圈是怎样的，你是怎么融入进去的？你知道，你是怎么开始的？对。你都做些什么？任何一个和我们同龄的孩子，
thinks of three things when they're 13. You wanna be a baseball player or a rock and roll star or an astronaut, you know? So you strum the tennis racket and you you think you can sing Yeah, when you're playing in the garage is in the school dance with your first band The benefit of that for me was that the drinking age in New Jersey was 18 So at 16 I could be playing in a bar and I loved it so much that I didn't have them and I didn't have the responsibilities of a career path yet, a job, a higher education thought.
在13岁时都会想到三件事。你想成为一名棒球运动员、摇滚巨星还是一名宇航员，你知道的？所以你拨弄着网球拍，你觉得自己会唱歌。是的，当你和你的第一支乐队在车库里、在学校舞会上演奏时。对我的好处是，新泽西州的法定饮酒年龄是18岁，所以在16岁时我就可以在酒吧里演出，我太喜欢了，以至于我当时还没有职业规划、工作、高等教育想法带来的那些责任。
It was like music, music, music. I like music. Because my parents were somewhat supportive, their attitude was, if you're going to be in a bar at one or two in the morning, at least we know where you are. They saw that I was really, really wanting to pursue that career path. And then I was also blessed because I wrote Runaway when I was 20.
那就像是音乐、音乐、音乐。我喜欢音乐。因为我的父母还算支持，他们的态度是，如果你要在凌晨一点或两点待在酒吧里，至少我们知道你在哪儿。他们看到我是真的、真的很想追求那个职业道路。然后我也很幸运，因为我在20岁时写了《Runaway》。
So I got a record deal at 21. Yeah, that was your first hit in... 1983, I put that out independently without the band and then got a record deal. And it's been the same record deal for 40 years. Wow, that's great. Wow. Amazing. Was it ever, so you started singing so young
所以我在21岁时就获得了唱片合约。对，那是你的第一首热门歌曲，在……1983年，我独立发行了那首歌，没有通过乐队，然后得到了唱片合约。而且这同一份唱片合约一签就是40年。哇，太棒了。哇。太神奇了。有没有——所以你很小就开始唱歌了，
that was singing uncool at that age? You know, because when I was a little kid, I always just thought singing was not cool because I was so young. What was it like at your age when you did it? All the centerfolds of Circus Magazine was pretty cool. Yeah, right. In the late 70s, it was Led Zeppelin and Aerosmith
那个年代唱歌很不酷吗？你知道的，因为当我还是个小孩子的时候，我总是觉得唱歌一点也不酷，因为我太年轻了。你那个年纪做这件事的时候是什么感觉？《马戏团》杂志（Circus Magazine）的所有中心页插图都挺酷的。对，没错。在70年代末，那是齐柏林飞船（Led Zeppelin）、史密斯飞船（Aerosmith）、
and Queen and Leonard Skinner and Springsteen and all the, and then remember that Bruce Springsteen and Southside Johnny were from 25 miles south of my house. So chances are with 10 Asbury Jukes and seven members of the E Street band, by playing in those bars, you're going to see real live rock stars. And when you're 16, that's like seeing Santa Claus.
皇后乐队（Queen）、林纳德·斯金纳（Lynyrd Skynyrd）、斯普林斯汀（Springsteen）的时代，然后记住布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀和索赛德·强尼（Southside Johnny）来自我家以南25英里远的地方。所以随着10个阿斯伯里点唱机乐队成员和7个E街乐队成员的出现，通过在那些酒吧里演出，你肯定能看到真正的活生生的摇滚巨星。当你16岁的时候，那就像看到圣诞老人一样。
So all of these things were incredibly inspirational. And being a lead singer in a rock band, Mr. Jason Sir, is pretty fucking good. I was gonna say more about ballads, probably, in my head, as opposed to a rock and roll stage. No, the ballads work. The ballads work. They work, too, right? Are you kidding? Of course the ballads work.
所以所有这些事情都极具鼓舞性。作为一个摇滚乐队的主唱，杰森·西尔先生，感觉他妈的太棒了。我本来想说，在我的脑海里，可能更多的是民谣，而不是摇滚舞台。不，民谣也管用。民谣管用。它们也管用，对吧？你在开玩笑吗？民谣当然管用。
Are you crazy, JP? Think it through, dude. Yeah, are you... But here's what blows my mind about your voice. I always comment about how, like, your pipes are just incredible. The fact that, whoa! I mean, that's like way, way, way, way up there. And not a lot of people can do that.
你疯了吗，JP？好好想想，老兄。对，你是……但有一点最让我对你的嗓音感到震惊。我总是评论说，天哪，你的嗓音（pipes）简直不可思议。事实上，哇！我的意思是，那简直是高、高、高、高到了天上。没多少人能做到这一点。
And where do you find, at such a young age, because people are already trepidatious about opening their mouth and am I gonna be able to sing? And you're just wailing, like where does that confidence come from like to really go for those notes at such a young age and write those songs that are massive? Naivete, I was too stupid to know any better. I didn't study.
你在那么年轻的时候是在哪里找到——因为人们对张开嘴唱歌总是战战兢兢的，我会不会唱？而你却在放声高歌，那种自信是从哪里来的，能在那么年轻的时候就勇敢地去挑战那些高音，并写出那些超级热门的歌曲？天真，我当时太蠢了，根本不懂什么叫好歹。我没有学过。
You just got in front of a mic and yelped until it made sense. I regret, that's a high C, Sean. The high note is a fucking C. It's crazy. It's like a soprano. It's not good. You know, I'm going to be 62 on Saturday.
你只是站在麦克风前大喊大叫，直到它听起来像那么回事。我很遗憾，那是高音C，肖恩。那个高音他妈的是个C。太疯狂了。就像女高音一样。这可不好。你知道的，我周六就要62岁了。
I'm 62 years old. Happy birthday. Hitting a high C... Can you do it? I can hit a, I can squeak out a C, yeah. Right, so does it start to leave just like, you know, Tom Brady ain't throwing anymore. Yeah, the big thing about this huge documentary
我62岁了。生日快乐。能唱出高音C……你能做到吗？我能唱出，我能挤出一个C来，对。没错，所以它开始退化了吗，就像——你知道的，汤姆·布雷迪（Tom Brady）已经不扔球了。对，关于我们刚完成的这部宏大纪录片，最重要的一件事，
that we just did, the parallel story and showing you relate to this, I underwent a massive surgery for the first time in my life. In your throat for your vocal cords? Oh wow, wow. Oh I didn't know that. That's scary. Yeah, that's what I'm going through right now.
就是平行展现的故事，你会对此感同身受，我经历了我人生中第一次重大手术。在你的喉咙里，为了声带？哦哇，哇。哦，我不知道这个。这太吓人了。对，这就是我正在经历的。
And hence this, but not your typical nodule. Because I really have studied singing for a lot of years. But I had what's called now a medialization. And if you're at all familiar with that. One chord was atrophying while the strong one was pushing the weak one around and I wasn't singing well. And it was, I couldn't understand it.
因此才有了这个，但不是那种典型的结节。因为我真的研究了很多年的唱歌。但我做了现在被称为“内移术”（medialization）的手术。如果你对这个稍有了解的话。一侧声带在萎缩，而强壮的一侧把虚弱的一侧挤在一边，我当时唱得不好。而且，我无法理解这一点。
And this is on the last two years since the surgery. And they put a plastic implant outside the chords to strengthen them. Wow. So I'm still in the rehab stage and it's disheartening. John, what was that like when you first noticed that? When you had that, do you remember having that first thing of like, shit, I'm not, yeah? And what you would do is compensate.
这是手术后的头两年发生的事。他们在声带外侧植入了塑料植入物来增强它们。哇。所以我现在还在康复阶段，这很让人沮丧。约翰，当你第一次注意到这一点时，那是什么感觉？当你经历那个的时候，你还记得那种第一感觉吗，比如，操，我不在状态，对吧？而你会做的是去弥补。
You're like, well, that didn't work today, so let me do it this way, let me do it this way. And finally you're standing on your head trying to hit a note, and you would compensate to a point where it just wasn't very good anymore. And other things start getting out of whack. Right, way out of whack. And then your mind.
你会想，好吧，今天这个不管用，那我换个方式，换个方式。最后你倒立着去唱一个音符，而你的弥补已经到了一个地步，它就是不再那么动听了。其他事情也开始失控了。没错，彻底失控了。然后是你的心理。
How are you feeling now, how's it going? I'm 20 months post-surgery, I would say I'm 90% there and you still gotta get the ghosts out of the machine as you guys are saying. The ones in your head. Yeah, for sure. The ones that are saying now that you're over, back to, let's just say you don't have to compensate
你现在感觉怎么样，情况如何？我做完手术20个月了，可以说我恢复了90%，而且正如你们所说，你还得把机器里的鬼魂赶出去。脑子里的那些。对，肯定的。那些声音在说，既然你已经恢复了，打个比方，你不再需要去弥补了，
anymore, your mind still has to remind your body that it's fixed. You don't have to compensate anymore. Right, right. What about the absolute panic and horror of going under the knife? And when I wake up, I hope that A, I can speak, and in a perfect world, I can still sing.
你的大脑仍然必须提醒你的身体它已经修好了。你不再需要去弥补了。对，对。开刀动手术时的绝对恐慌和恐惧是怎样的？当我醒来时，我希望A，我还能说话，在理想世界里，我还能唱歌。
Like, I'm sure your research on doctors must have been intense. Yeah, and this is what I do, right? This is, I'm sure your research on doctors must have been intense. Yeah, and this is what I do, right? This is, I'm a singer. Yeah, the doctor, I knew the doctor that did Julie Andrews. So we all, you and I both know that story. And you went to him too, and so did I for a lot of years. Yeah.
就像，我确信你对医生的研究一定很深入。对，这就是我所做的，对吧？这是——我确信你对医生的研究一定很深入。对，这就是我所做的，对吧？我是一个歌手。对，那个医生，我认识为主治朱莉·安德鲁斯（Julie Andrews）动手术的那个医生。所以我们都知道，你和我都知道那个故事。你也去找过他，我很多年里也找过他。对。
And then, but the guy that I found in Philadelphia, the greatest thing he said after I exhausted everything, every bit of what I call voodoo, every Eastern medicine, every laser, every dietary singing lessons, everything I possibly could, and I did 15 shows and it just was not working. And I went to see him and I said, I can give you 100% of 80%.
然后，但在费城找到的那个人，在我用尽了一切办法——我称之为巫术的一切办法、所有的东方医学、所有的激光、所有的饮食歌唱课、所有我能做的一切，并且我演了15场演出但就是不管用之后——他说过最棒的一句话是：我只能向你保证80%里的100%。
And he says, isn't that good enough? And I said, no, I'm gonna quit. He says, now we can talk about this surgery. And he says, and that good enough? And I said, no, I'm gonna quit. He says, now we can talk about this surgery. And he says, and I guarantee you nothing. He says, but if you work hard, this will give you your best shot. So I've been diligent in my recovery and hoping that everything's gonna be all right,
他说，这还不够好吗？我说，不，我要退出了。他说，现在我们可以谈谈这个手术了。他说，这还不够好吗？我说，不，我要退出了。他说，现在我们可以谈谈这个手术了。他说，我什么也不向你保证。他说，但如果你努力，这会给你最好的机会。所以我一直在努力康复，希望一切都会好起来，
but I don't know. Are you bullish on being able to get out there and tour again? I'm hoping to be. I'm being bluntly honest. If I'm not great, I'm not going. But hang on. I mean, there are plenty of musicians and bands
但我不知道。你对重返舞台巡演有信心吗？我希望如此。我直言不讳地说。如果我状态不好，我就不去了。等一下。我是说，有很多音乐人和乐队
that I would easily pay top dollars to go see. But even if they can't make the song sound like it did when they recorded it fucking 30 years ago, I still wanna see them doing it and just move the mic away from their mouth a little bit when they reach for that high seat. I mean, but. Look at John's like, no.
是我愿意花大价钱去看他们演出的。但即使他们唱不出三十年前录音时的那种感觉，我还是想看他们表演，当他们唱高音时，把话筒稍微拿开一点就行了。我是说，但是。你看约翰的表情，好像在说“才不”。
But you're providing more than incredible singing. You guys are the watch. We wanna see you, John. Watch YouTube. I'm not interested Well, what about your bandmates what are they are they are they are they are they understanding of that position or are they saying fucking? Come on. No, you know, we are we are actively rehearsing. We did a couple of days this week. Everybody was here in New Jersey Just running it hard for a couple of days and seeing, measuring the progress.
但你提供的不仅仅是精彩的歌声。你们是整个乐队。我们想看你，约翰，去看YouTube吧。我没兴趣。好吧，那你的乐队成员呢？他们对这种立场是理解的，还是会说“操，拜托”？不，你知道的，我们一直在积极排练。这周我们排练了几天。大家都来到了新泽西，连续几天拼命排练，看看并评估进展情况。
Oh, that's great. Because I have this great new record, I feel optimistic about the record, I love the film. A guy named Deepak, Deepak, Gotham Chopra, Deepak's son directed it. It was a two year, four part docu-series that'll air on Hulu, but I'm very happy with it,
哦，那太好了。因为我有一张很棒的新专辑，我对这张专辑感到乐观，我也很喜欢这部纪录片。一个叫迪帕克、迪帕克·戈瑟姆·乔普拉、迪帕克儿子的人导演的。这是一部历时两年、共四集的纪录片系列，将在Hulu上播出，但我对它非常满意，
because it's on the band. Yeah. Yeah, that's so great. It's our 40th anniversary right now. I can't wait to see that. That's so mind blowing, 40 years. I feel like I became really, well, like a lot of people, really well aware of you guys with the massive,
因为它是关于乐队的。是啊。是啊，太棒了。我们现在迎来了40周年纪念。我迫不及待想看了。真是令人难以置信，40年了。我觉得我真正开始——嗯，就像很多人一样——对你们有深刻的印象，是通过那首巨大的、
first of all, your massive hit, Living on a Prayer, which... Well, there's tons in there. Yeah, you could say that. There's tons of them, but that was the... 10 different songs. Of course, but that's sort of the, for me, that was the first one that really,
首先是你们的大热单曲《Living on a Prayer》，那首歌……嗯，里面有很多歌。对，你可以这么说。有很多歌，但那是……10首不同的歌。当然，但对我来说，那是第一首真正让我...
I was like, holy shit, and that, you guys kind of, do you remember the first time playing that, when it was a hit and playing it in front of an audience and everybody going like, fuck yeah. Maybe not the first time, but what was interesting about that song is we really didn't know what we had because it was so different.
我觉得，卧槽，然后你们那种，你还记得第一次演奏那首歌时的情景吗，当它成为热门单曲，在观众面前演奏时，每个人都兴奋得爆粗口。也许不是第一次，但那首歌有趣的地方在于，我们真的不知道自己手里有什么宝贝，因为它是如此与众不同。
It didn't sound like anything on the radio. And it had a Motown kind of a baseline. It had the boy girl story that is almost Shakespearean at the end of the day. And it's so, You Give Love a Bad Name was the first single on that record and it was a number one song and that was pretty evident and obvious that it would be.
它听起来不像广播里的任何歌。它有一种摩城风格的贝斯线。它有一个男孩女孩的故事，到头来几乎像莎士比亚的作品一样。它是那么的，《You Give Love a Bad Name》是那张专辑的第一首单曲，它是一首冠军单曲，这一点非常明显，大家都知道它会火。
But when we put out Living on a Prayer, I thought, yeah, it should be second because who knows what it's gonna do. And then of course, you know, it's one of the biggest pop songs of all time. Of all. We'll be right back. This episode of Smartless is brought to you in part
但当我们推出《Living on a Prayer》时，我想，是的，它应该是第二首，因为谁知道它会怎么样。然后当然，你知道，它是史上最伟大的流行歌曲之一。史上最伟大的。我们马上回来。本期Smartless节目部分赞助商为
by Skinny Pop Popcorn. Looking for some excitement? Well, do that on your own time, but in the meantime, check out Skinny Pop's new Cheddar Jalapeno Popcorn. Made with real cheddar cheese and a pop of jalapeno. This new flavor is sure to spice up your daily snacking routine. Listen, I love skinny pop popcorn and look, I request this is actually a true thing.
Skinny Pop爆米花。想找点刺激？好吧，请在闲暇时间去吧，但在此期间，来看看Skinny Pop推出的全新切达墨西哥辣椒味爆米花吧。采用真正的切达干酪和少许墨西哥辣椒制成。这款新口味一定会为你的日常零食时间增添无限风味。听着，我喜欢Skinny Pop爆米花，听着，我要求——这其实是个真事。
Sometimes when you're going out on a job in the line of work I'm in, which is obviously entertainment and no, I don't work for the government in some super highly classified capacity And I can't confirm and or deny anything the point is this they asked me if I want stuff when I'm at work like as as part of the my refreshment Selection and skinny pop popcorn is always there. That is a true story And Skinny Pop popcorn is always there. That is a true story. So Skinny Pop is light and tasty and perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go,
有时当你从事我这种类型的工作时，显然是娱乐行业，不，我不是为政府从事某种高度机密的工作，我也不能确认或否认任何事情，重点是这个：他们问我在工作时是否想要点什么，比如作为我茶点选择的一部分，而Skinny Pop爆米花总是在那里。这是个真事。而Skinny Pop爆米花总是在那里。这是个真事。所以Skinny Pop轻盈美味，适合任何场合，无论你是在旅途中，
staving off boredom or unwinding after a long day. A deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil and salt. Every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more. In addition to the original popcorn, Skin skinny pop offers a variety of delicious flavors Ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle all perfectly popped endlessly Delicious let me tell you something also that salty kettle forget it just forget it You're gonna be on a delicious ride to
排解无聊，还是在漫长的一天后放松身心。爆米花、油和盐的美味简单组合。每一口完美爆开的原味爆米花都让你回味无穷。除了原味爆米花，Skinny Pop还提供各种美味口味，从白切达乳酪到香甜海盐焦糖，每一款都完美爆开，美味无极限，我还要告诉你，还有那种海盐焦糖味，忘了吧，直接忘了吧。你将开启一段美味的
fantastic town shop skinny pop now ride to Fantastic Town. Shop Skinny Pop now! We get support from Organic Valley. With Organic Valley, you can feel good choosing their dairy products. Their products are ethically sourced from small family farms where cows spend lots of time grazing outside on organic pasture. Since 1988, Organic Valley has helped minimize the impact on the earth and grow a more sustainable food system. It's through this dedication to regenerative
奇妙小镇之旅，现在就购买Skinny Pop，开启奇妙小镇之旅。我们的支持来自Organic Valley。选择Organic Valley，你可以安心享用他们的乳制品。他们的产品均来自道德采购的小型家庭农场，那里的奶牛有大量时间在有机牧场户外吃草。自1988年以来，Organic Valley一直致力于将对地球的影响降到最低，并建立一个更具可持续性的食品系统。正是由于对再生
organic farming practices that has made Organic Valley America's low carbon footprint dairy contributing significantly to the fight against climate change. At Organic Valley, every day is Earth Day where you can enjoy delicious high quality organic milk which comes from pasture raised cows producing fewer carbon emissions compared to factory or industrial farms.
有机耕作方式的奉献，Organic Valley成为了美国碳足迹最低的乳制品品牌，为应对气候变化做出了重大贡献。在Organic Valley，天天都是地球日，你可以享用美味的高品质有机牛奶，它们来自放养奶牛，与工厂化或工业化农场相比，产生的碳排放更少。
I mean, they sent me this stuff and I buy it in the store anyways. You know, I drink milk like at every meal. That's how I grew up. And now they sent my sister some Organic Valley stuff. I love you guys. Thanks, that's so sweet of you. When you choose Organic Valley, not only will you enjoy great tasting organic dairy, you'll help save over 1,600 small organic family farms who are protecting over 400,000 acres of organic farmland
我是说，他们给我寄了这些东西，我平时在店里也会买。你知道的，我每顿饭都喝牛奶。我就是这么长大的。现在他们给我姐姐也寄了一些Organic Valley的产品。我爱你们。谢谢，你们太贴心了。当你选择Organic Valley时，不仅能享用到美味的有机乳制品，还能帮助拯救1600多家小型有机家庭农场，它们保护着超过40万英亩的有机农田，
and all the plants and animals that call it home. To find Organic Valley Dairy near you, visit ov.coop. Hey, smart list listener, we're supported by Mint Mobile. After years of fine print contracts and getting ripped off by overpriced wireless providers, if we've learned anything it's that there's always a catch. So when I heard that for a limited time all Mint Mobile wireless plans are $15 a month when you purchase a three month plan, I thought, what's the catch? There isn't one.
以及所有以之为家的动植物。要寻找你附近的Organic Valley乳制品，请访问ov.coop。嘿，Smartless听众，我们得到了Mint Mobile的支持。在经历了多年的小字合同和被 overpriced 无线运营商坑了之后，如果我们学到了什么，那就是天下没有免费的午餐。所以当我听说限时所有Mint Mobile无线套餐只需每月15美元，当你购买三个月的套餐时，我想，这里面有什么套路？根本没有。
Mint Mobile's secret sauce is that they sell wireless service online. They cut out the cost of retail stores and pass those sweet savings directly to you. Say bye-bye to your overpriced wireless plans, jaw-dropping monthly bills, and unexpected overages. Mint Mobile is here to rescue you with premium wireless plans starting at 15 bucks a month. All plans come with high speed data and unlimited talk and text delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Plus you can use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and bring your phone number along with all your existing contacts.
Mint Mobile的秘诀在于他们在线销售无线服务。他们省去了零售店的成本，并将这些丰厚的省下来的钱直接回馈给你。向你 overpriced 的无线套餐、惊人的月账单和意想不到的超额费用说再见吧。Mint Mobile来拯救你了，提供每月15美元起的高级无线套餐。所有套餐都包含高速数据以及在全美最大的5G网络上提供的无限通话和短信。此外，你可以在任何Mint Mobile套餐中使用你自己的手机，并保留你的手机号以及所有现有的联系人。
To get this new customer offer and your new three month unlimited wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month, go to mintmobile.com slash smartless. That's mintmobile.com slash smartless. Cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com slash smartless. $45 upfront payment required equivalent to $15 a month.
要获得这项新客户优惠，并以每月仅15美元的价格获得你的新三个月无限无线套餐，请访问mintmobile.com斜杠smartless。网址是mintmobile.com斜杠smartless。将你的无线账单削减至每月15美元，请访问mintmobile.com斜杠smartless。需要提前支付45美元，相当于每月15美元。
New customers on first three month plan only. Speed slow after 40 gigabytes per month on unlimited plan. Additional taxes, fees, and restrictions apply. See Mint Mobile for details. And now back to the show. Can I tell you something about You Give Love a Bad Name? I guess. So my first dog was named Buzzy,
仅限前三个月套餐的新客户。无限套餐每月40GB后网速变慢。适用额外的税费、费用和限制。详情请查阅Mint Mobile。现在回到节目中。我能跟你讲讲《You Give Love a Bad Name》的事吗？好吧。我养的第一只狗叫巴兹，
and when I was potty training him, he would go outside and he would poop on the lawn. So I changed the words from what they are to, there's poop on the lawn and you're to blame Buzzy, you give dogs a bad name. I love that. Thank you, Sean. You're welcome. There's poop on the lawn and you're too blame.
当我在训练它定点大小便时，它会去外面，在草坪上大便。所以我把歌词改成了，草坪上有大便，都是你的错，巴兹，你给狗丢脸了。我太喜欢这个了。谢谢你，肖恩。不客气。草坪上有大便，都是你的错。
This is the family member that you just stop inviting. You know? No, we're not having Thanksgiving this year, Sean. Sorry. You know? Wait, I have other stories. Sean, tell me more about your music career because I didn't get the chance,
这就是那种你会停止邀请的家庭成员。你知道吗？不，我们今年不过感恩节了，肖恩。抱歉。你知道吗？等等，我还有别的故事。肖恩，多跟我讲讲你的音乐生涯，因为我之前没有机会，
but Dorothea saw the play. Oh, so good. My wife saw the play and was talking so incredibly about not only your playing, but your singing as well. How did you keep it eight days a week? Well, that's so nice. It was just a play. I didn't sing, but I played.
但多萝西亚看了那部戏剧。哦，太棒了。我妻子看了那部戏剧，对你的表演和歌唱赞不绝口。你是怎么做到一周八场连轴转的？哦，太好了。那只是一部戏剧。我没有唱歌，但我演了。
Oh, you didn't have to sing? No, thank, I'll never do that again. But his voice, she was probably a play, I didn't sing, but I played. Oh, you didn't have to sing? No, I'll never do that again. But his voice, she was probably talking about, he did a whole different voice for this character. I remember Will and I, Will, did we look at each other? When he came out, I think we've told this story. It's a big swing. A big swing, looked at each other like,
哦，你不用唱歌？不，谢谢，我再也不那样做了。但他的声音，她可能说的是，他为这个角色用了完全不同的声音。我记得威尔和我，威尔，我们对视了一眼吗？当他走出来时，我想我们讲过这个故事。这是一个很大的冒险。一个很大的冒险，对视了一眼，心想，
oh boy, here we fucking go. Because it's one of those moments, John, where you're like, it's either gonna be great or it's gonna be terrible. What are we gonna say to him backstage? And like 30 seconds past that point, it's like, oh no, we're in good hands. He's pulling this off.
哦，天哪，我们要来真的了。因为这是那种时刻，约翰，你会觉得，要么大获成功，要么一败涂地。我们在后台要对他说什么呢？大约过了30秒钟，感觉就像是，哦不，我们有救了。他成功驾驭了。
And it was a big, it was a different voice, a whole gate and everything. I said to Jason when I saw him right after the show, I said, can I guess your thought bubble when I first came out? He said, yeah, and it was just, uh-oh. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
这是一个很大的改变，换了一种声音，整个步态都变了。演出结束后我见到杰森时对他说，我能猜到我刚出场时你的内心独白吗？他说，可以，那就是，糟糕。糟糕。糟糕。
Wait, John, did you ever do Broadway? Did you ever do a show on Broadway? No. No, God, you were great. No, the stage to me is the stage. So I didn't need that. I didn't need that even in the learning experience. For me, when I went in to try to learn to act,
等等，约翰，你演过百老汇吗？你在百老汇演过剧吗？没有。不，天哪，你太棒了。不，对我来说，舞台就是舞台。所以我不需要那个。我甚至不需要把它当作一次学习经历。对我来说，当我开始尝试学习表演时，
and I studied for a couple years before I ever even went for an audition, it was the opportunity to grow in the arts. It was just a different avenue in the arts that I could bring that back then to the fold, different material to write about, different humility, standing on the audition line, you know, being turned down before you even walked into the room.
我在试镜前学习了好几年，那是艺术成长的机会。那是艺术中一个不同的领域，我可以把它带回我的领域，可以写不同题材的故事，体验不同的谦逊，站在试镜的队伍里，（你知道的），还没走进房间就被拒绝了。
And all of that humility that I brought back while I was learning about the craft was incredibly formative. What was your feeling about that as you were starting to learn about acting and quote unquote study it? Because I'm always sort of a little pessimistic about if it's something we can learn to do I think it's all something we all know how to do it's freeing yourself up but like did you think it was like oh this is a real craft a real art form that I'm enjoying or were you like oh this is just learning how to be full of shit I mean both both are valid both are true but there's just just different perspectives
所有这些在我学习表演技艺时带回的谦逊，对我有着极其重要的塑造作用。当你开始学习表演、所谓“研究”它时，你对此有什么感觉？因为我总是对这到底是不是一件我们可以学会做的事持有点悲观的态度，我觉得这其实是我们所有人本就会的事，只是在于解放自我。但你当时觉得，哦，这是一门真正的技艺、真正的艺术形式，我很享受，还是觉得，哦，这只是在学习如何满口胡言？我是说，两者都成立，两者都是真的，但只是对它是什么以及如何看待它有不同的视角，
on what it is and how to where did it find itself on you? I just have too much respect for y'all, and I immensely respect the craft, and I wouldn't dare think that even Pacino or De Niro, if I put a microphone in their face and said, "'Sing me a song,' that they'd be any good at it. I think in order to be good at it, you should learn how to do it."
你在它身上找到了什么？我只是对你们所有人有太多的尊重，我极其尊重这门手艺，我绝不敢认为，即使把麦克风塞到帕西诺或德尼罗的脸前对他们说“给我唱首歌”，他们就能唱得有多好。我认为要想把它做好，你必须先学会怎么做。
Yeah, amen. And so I studied for two years privately not in classes But privately until I was confident enough to even you know, try to get an audition Yeah, I had too much respect for it Yeah, and what was the one things that you that made you feel like you wanted to take on that challenge of? Expanding your creative juices from music to acting? I had had five records by that point and Slippery was our third, that was a monster, New Jersey was a monster.
是的，阿门。所以我私下里学习了两年，不是去上课，而是私下学习，直到我有足够的信心去（你知道的）尝试争取一个试镜机会。是的，我对它太尊重了。是的，是什么原因让你想要接受那个挑战，将你的创作热情从音乐扩展到表演？到那时我已经出了五张专辑了，《Slippery》是第三张，大获成功，《New Jersey》也大获成功。
Then I wrote the soundtrack to the Young Guns record and I, you know, I win all the awards with that. So there was this kind of stupid ego moment in the band's history where you're like, you think you're too smart. The incredible thing about starting over with something in the arts that you know nothing about but you've had so many other life experiences,
然后我为《年轻的枪手》写了电影原声带，（你知道的），我凭那个赢了所有的奖。所以乐队历史上有过那么一段愚蠢的自我膨胀时期，你会觉得自己太聪明了。从你一无所知但拥有许多其他人生经历的艺术新领域重新开始，这种感觉是不可思议的，
brings you a great humility. And so that when you take that back to music, it was an opportunity for me to share that with the guys and for them to then learn from that. You know, and it humbled all of us to go. I think that's a big reason why when we went into the 90s and the grunge movement happened, we didn't even slow down. We still had hits.
它带给你极大的谦逊。所以当你把这种谦逊带回音乐中时，这是一个与伙伴们分享的机会，也能让他们从中学习。你知道的，这让我们所有人都放下了架子。我认为这也是为什么当我们进入90年代、垃圾摇滚运动兴起时，我们甚至没有放慢脚步。我们依然有热门歌曲。
We still kept going. We had more international growth than ever. And all of that was, I think, a direct result of my sitting in that basement apartment in Manhattan with Harold Guskin for years, you know, getting yelled at. And so I really, really loved the process of acting. The bitch was whenever, and you guys know this well, I would go in and they'd say,
我们依然在前进。我们的国际影响力比以往任何时候都要大。这一切，我认为都直接源于我在曼哈顿的地下室公寓里跟哈罗德·古斯金一起坐了多年（你知道的）挨训的经历。所以我真的、真的很喜欢表演的过程。麻烦在于，无论什么时候——你们对此也很清楚——当我进去时，他们会说，
anytime you get a spark in this town, you take off for a year and go on the road. We don't think you're serious about it. I said, I'm fucking serious about it, but you pay me two cents, and I'm six on the call sheet. What am I gonna do here? There's a stadium waiting in, you know, wherever.
你在镇上刚有点起色，就要离开一年去巡演。我们觉得你对表演不够严肃。我说，我是他妈认真的，但你们付我两分钱，我在演员表里排第六。我在这里能做什么？体育场还在（你知道的）某地等着呢。
Right, right, right. What was that first film that I remember you did? Moonlight in Valentino was a girly movie I did. Moonlight in Valentino, yes. Yeah, with Gwyneth and Whoopi and Kathleen Turner and Liz Perkins. So do you remember the... So let's talk about that.
对，对，对。我记得你演的第一部电影是什么来着？《月光下情奔》那是一部女性电影。是的，《月光下情奔》。对，和格温妮丝、乌比、凯瑟琳·特纳还有莉兹·珀金斯一起。那么你还记得……我们来聊聊这个吧。
So you, I mean, you talk about it, but like you're a massive international superstar, rock star, and then you go on the set of this movie and it's a new thing that you've just been sort of learning about. That first day on set, that first take. Oh, yeah. So I say I'll never forget it. The director was a guy named David Onspach who had done Hoosiers and Rudy.
所以你，我是说，你谈到了这个，但就像你是一个巨大的国际超级巨星、摇滚巨星，然后你走上这部电影的片场，这是你刚刚开始了解的新事物。片场的第一天，第一个镜头。哦，是的。所以我说我永远不会忘记。导演是个叫大卫·昂斯帕奇的家伙，他拍过《火爆教头》和《追梦赤子心》。
And so he was a guy's guy writing those kind of movies. He's got four ladies as his stars. I'm the cute, you know, house painter. We're doing take two, take three, take four. After the girls are giving him like one take a piece and walking off the set, and he's going take two, take three. And I walked over to him, I said, David, I'm sorry, we have to do so many takes, I'll pay for the film.
所以他是个拍那种电影的纯爷们儿。他的主演有四位女士。而我呢，是个可爱的、你知道的，油漆匠。我们在拍第二条、第三条、第四条。在姑娘们每人拍了一条就离开片场之后，他还一直在说“第二条”、“第三条”、“第四条”。我走过去对他说：“大卫，对不起，我们得拍这么多条，胶片钱我来出。”
He says, this is how we make movies. Oh my God, that's so sweet. Now, were you encouraged? It must have been nerve-racking though. Yeah, I'll bet it was nerve-racking, but did you find some sort of encouragement and inspiration that you weren't the first of like Sting and David Bowie, they did some great performances.
他说：“我们就是这样拍电影的。”哦天哪，太贴心了。那么，你当时受到鼓励了吗？不过那一定很伤脑筋吧。对啊，我敢打赌这肯定让人焦虑，但你有没有从中找到某种鼓励和启发？因为你并不是第一批跨界的人，比如斯汀和大卫·鲍伊，他们都有过很棒的表演。
Was that inspirational for you? No, because they'd all, by definition, weren't successful. You may look back and think that those movies were cool, but we were, as musicians, told, you do either or. Bowie and Madonna and whatever, no, there's musicians that want to act. They're not allowed to freely do both the way Sinatra could. But what were your expectations?
这对外于你来说有启发吗？没有，因为按定义来说，他们当时都不算成功。你现在回过头看，可能会觉得那些电影很酷，但我们作为音乐人，当时被灌输的观念是：你只能二选一。鲍伊、麦当娜等等，不行，有些音乐人想去演戏，他们不能像当年的弗兰克·辛纳屈那样，毫无束缚地两边都做。但你当时有什么期望？
You weren't possibly looking to match your level of success with acting that you had. It wasn't based on success, it was based on opportunity. So that the opportunities just kept going down and down and down and then suddenly you're making like an indie to an indie and I'm sitting on the curb outside of CAA like with a tear in my eye. LAUGHING
你不可能指望在表演上达到你在音乐上那种成功的高度。这不是基于成功，而是基于机会。所以机会越来越少、越来越少，然后突然之间你就在拍一部又一部的独立电影，而我坐在CAA外面的马路牙子上，眼含泪水。笑声
But did you... What have I done? But did you find that... I mentioned that you were in the Songwriters Hall of Fame. You're such a great songwriter and lyricist and music and everything. And did you find when you were acting throughout the years, did you find that sort of common thing as an artist as you're doing it, sort of the beats of it?
但你……我到底做了什么？但你有没有发现……我提到过你是词曲创作名人堂成员。你是一位如此优秀的词曲创作者，懂音乐，什么都懂。你在多年后的演艺生涯中，有没有发现作为艺术家，在做这件事时有某种相通的东西，也就是它的节奏？
Was there a commonality between being a performer, being a singer, songwriter, and being an actor? What was that kind of? I think there are commonalities, but again, I think the biggest thing to me was that finding something else in the arts that gave me an opportunity to grow. It wasn't like I went from singing to building cars, you know, one has nothing at all to do with the other.
作为一个表演者、一个唱作人和一个演员之间，有共通性吗？那是一种什么样的……我觉得是有共通性的，但话说回来，对我来说最大的一点是，在艺术中找到了能给我提供成长机会的别的东西。这不像是从唱歌转行去造车，你知道的，这两者完全风马牛不相及。
This is another way to emote, this is another way to tell a story, this is more information for me to write about because, you know, all I had to write about between 21 and 30 was life on the road, to be honest with you. I was nowhere near as seasoned a man as Bob Dylan or Woody Guthrie. I was writing pop songs in a rock and roll band in a very sheltered, middle American,
这是另一种表达情感的方式，这是另一种讲故事的方式，这为我提供了更多可以写入歌中的素材，因为说实话，在21岁到30岁之间，我能写的只有巡演生活。我远没有鲍勃·迪伦或伍迪·格思里那样阅历丰富。我只是在一个非常温室般的、美国中产阶级的、
white, suburban life. So going and learning about, I don't know, Tennessee Williams and coming home and writing something and thinking, ooh, why did I get to write Blazer Glory and the whole Young Gun soundtrack when my hands on a script, I know how to do that. Yeah, I know. Does it still hold interest for you?
白人郊区生活里，在摇滚乐队里写流行歌。所以去了解——我不知道——田纳西·威廉姆斯，然后回家写点东西，心想：哦，为什么我能写出《年轻枪手》的原声带和《Blazer Glory》，当我的手拿到剧本时，我知道该怎么做。对，我知道。这东西对你现在还有吸引力吗？
Where does it sit now for you, the acting? I would have to stop doing music and go back to really working hard on the craft. You know, I have far too much respect for it to think, sure, send me a role, I'm ready to go. Well, is it sitting there sort of in second position to as you start to see, like, let's see how the voice does and if the voice is not to your standards,
对你来说，演戏现在处于什么位置？我必须停止做音乐，回去重新真正努力去打磨这门手艺。你知道的，我对它有着太多的尊重，不能去想“行啊，给我个角色，我随时准备开干”。好吧，那它是不是有点退居其次了？因为你开始看到——让我们看看嗓音恢复得怎么样，如果嗓音达不到你的标准，
maybe we can look forward to seeing more acting from you? I wouldn't be, I wouldn't say no for sure. I would just make sure I did it right. Yeah, what about producing music or producing other arts and stuff? I did all that early on. I don't need any more egos in the studio. I got a big enough one myself.
也许我们以后还能看到你更多的表演？我不会……我绝对不会把话说死。我只会确保如果我去做，就要把它做好。对了，制作音乐或者制作其他艺术品呢？我很早就把这些都做过了。我不需要录音室里再多几个自我意识过剩的人了。我自己的就已经够大了。
Okay, well Sean, you can log off. Okay. No. I mean. Hey, well Sean, you can log off. Okay. Okay. I mean. Hey, did you, forgive me, did you see, did you see the We Are the World documentary? Yes. Yeah. Yes.
好吧，肖恩，你可以退出了。好的。不。我是说。嘿，好吧，肖恩，你可以退出了。好的。好的。我是说。嘿，你，原谅我，你看了吗？你看了那个《我们是世界》的纪录片吗？看过。对。看过。
Wasn't that, yeah, incredible. I wanna see that. Just all those people coming together, wow. I'd never even thought about that they were there through the night. Yeah, I know. And at six in the morning, they're waiting for their solo line.
那不是，对啊，太不可思议了。我想看那个。所有那些人聚在一起，哇。我甚至从未想过他们通宵都在那里。对，我懂。到了早上六点，他们还在等自己的独唱部分。
And Bruce and Cyndi Lauper are just cock-eyed still, just being good sports about it all. I mean, you were missed in that. I was like, where's? I was just a little too young. I had two albums out by that point. I wasn't big enough. Oh, all right.
而布鲁斯和辛迪·劳帕依然是一脸迷糊、斜着眼，但对整件事都表现得很配合。我是说，大家都在里面，唯独漏了你。我就在想，人在哪儿？我当时稍微年轻了一点。那时候我才发了两张专辑。我还不够大牌。哦，原来如此。
I wasn't big enough yet. But go back to the performing in big arenas and shows and stuff and fans and dealing with fans and stuff like that. Is there any kind of, was there any kind of moment, have you ever had any kind of crazy happening on stage with a fan that was just completely through the show? Sure, I mean all the cliche stuff.
我当时还不够大牌。不过回到在大型体育场和演出中表演，面对粉丝以及诸如此类的事情上来。有没有那么一瞬间，你是否曾在舞台上遇到过什么疯狂的粉丝事件，完全把演出打乱了？当然，我是说那些老套的事情。
People screaming and. That kind of stuff is. Rushing the stage. Girls throw you their underwear. I mean, you're the... Everybody got to be, that's not even original because you know what I mean, it's sort of, every kid got to be Justin Bieber to Justin Timberlake
人们尖叫，还有……那种事情就是……冲上舞台。女孩们把内衣扔给你。我是说，你就是……每个人都得经历，这甚至都不是原创的，因为你知道我的意思，这有点像是，从贾斯汀·比伯到贾斯汀·汀布莱克，每个时代的年轻人都要经历这些，
all the way back to Elvis, you know, it's just, I with Harry Styles, you know, all that. Yeah, yeah, for sure. And how do you or any of those people you just mentioned avoid the intoxication and complete transitioning into, well, I'm God, and it's never going to be anything different and you end up buying the ego that you, in retrospect, should have been renting.
一直追溯到猫王，你知道的，还有哈里·斯泰尔斯，所有这些。对，对，确实如此。那你或你刚才提到的那些人，是怎么避免被这种陶醉感完全吞噬的？就是那种“好吧，我是上帝，而且情况永远不会变了”，然后你最终买下了本该在回顾时只租不买的自我。
But how do you avoid that big pitfall of, it's never gonna be any less than this? Because you're in a 360 of idolization that it's gotta be impossible to not- Or to make right size. Jump into, yeah. I don't know, I mean for me it was- You seem so balanced.
但你如何避免那个巨大的陷阱，觉得“情况永远不会比这更差了”？因为你身处一种360度的偶像化包围中，不可能不……或者说如何保持清醒。陷入其中，对。我不知道，对我来说——你看起来太平衡了。
Not being there where y'all are. For me that was one thing. I bought the house in Malibu. It's standing out of California. I bought the house on the beach in Malibu and my wife and I looked at each other and said, not for me. But I, cause I knew what the lifestyle was
没有像你们那样身处其中。对我来说那是重要的一点。我在马利布买了栋房子。那是加州的房产。我在马利布的海滩上买了栋房子，我和我妻子看着对方说：“这不适合我。”但我，因为我知道那种生活方式是什么样的，
and we were caught up in it. A lot of those people, you know, we had a house right on the beach, right? We're all at the height of everybody's craziness. And that was one of the things that we said, let's go back to New Jersey where there's no Joneses to keep up with. Let's go back to what we know.
而且我们都被卷进去了。那些人中的很多，你知道的，我们在海滩上正好有一栋房子，对吧？我们当时都处于每个人最疯狂的顶峰。而那是我们说过的事情之一，让我们回新泽西去吧，那里没有需要互相攀比的邻居。让我们回到我们熟悉的生活中去。
You mentioned it, John, your wife Dorothea, who I've also had the great pleasure and honor of spending a little bit of time with, getting to know a little bit, and she's such an awesome person. And I was thinking like, yeah, you didn't fault any of those pitfalls. You grew up, I mean, and when I say grew up, I mean like, sir, your 20s, those formative years,
你提到了，约翰，你的妻子多罗西亚，我也曾有幸和她共度了一段时光，稍微了解了她一下，她真的是个太棒的人。我在想，是的，你没有掉进任何那些陷阱里。你长大了，我是说，当我指长大时，我是指，你的20岁，那些塑造你人格的岁月里，
you were a massive star. You and Dorothea, were you guys in it together? Did that help keep you grounded? Absolutely. We've been together since high school. So for us, that was, yeah, we grew together. Yeah, so she's seen the whole ride. And then she didn't have to buy into something
你已经是一个超级巨星了。你和多罗西亚，你们是一起经历的吗？这有助于让你保持脚踏实地吗？绝对是的。我们从高中就认识了。所以对我们来说，那段时光，是的，我们是一起成长的。是的，所以她见证了整个过程。然后她不需要去相信什么外界的浮华，
or I didn't have to doubt her commitment to it. And then I could fall in the gutter throughout the course of it. And she could say, OK, I got it. I know why. And let's pick it up and go from here. So yeah, I give her the credit for so much of it. How lucky are you that you have that,
或者我也不用去怀疑她对这段感情的承诺。因此，在这个过程中无论我怎么跌入谷底，她都可以说：“好吧，我懂。我知道原因是什么，让我们重新振作起来，从这里继续。”所以，是的，我把很大一部分功劳归功于她。你有这样的伴侣，你有多幸运啊？
you had this partner with you? Oh, I know. Right? Yeah, we're married 35 years already. Bono went through the same thing. Yeah, yeah. His wife, it's just incredible. So John, we always talk about to people
哦，我懂。对吧？是的，我们已经结婚35年了。博诺也经历过同样的事。对，对。他的妻子，真的太不可思议了。所以约翰，我们经常和音乐界的人聊起，关于先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，你是先写歌词，还是先写曲？聊聊你的创作过程，是什么启发了你用某种特定方式创作而不是其他方式？你的嗓音比其他人更适合唱民谣，虽然其他风格也很棒，但你有一副极具抒情色彩的嗓音。谢谢。
who are in the music world about like chicken and the egg, do you write the lyrics, do you write the music first? Talk about your process, what inspires you to write a certain way as opposed to other? And do you like, your voice lends itself to ballad so much more than the other stuff and it's all great, but you have such a lyric voice. Well, thank you.
两种顺序都有过，但对我来说，我想说绝大多数情况下都是先有一个歌名，因为对我来说，歌名决定了音乐的基调。然后，你知道的，我再去写歌词。比如你喜欢的东西。
It's come both ways, but for me, I would like to say the slim majority of it comes from a title first, because for me that dictates the feel of the music. And then, you know, I write the lyrics. Something that you, like. You know, wanted dead or alive is, you know, that kind for the record. Something that you like. You know, Wanted Dead or Alive is, you know, that kind of a feeling of an open D chord.
你知道的，《通缉：死或生》就是那种——为了录音室效果——那种感觉，一个开放的D和弦。它自然而然就需要这种感觉。而《Better Roses》则需要完全不同的东西。你知道的，那首歌本来就是为了用钢琴弹奏而创作的。但创作过程取决于具体情况。我们在新冠疫情期间发行过一张名为《2020》的专辑，那是一张时事主题的专辑。所以它涵盖了从枪支管制
It just, it calls for that. And Better Roses would call for something else. You know, that was, it was sort of meant to be written on a piano. But the process depends on the situation. We had a record out in the midst of COVID called 2020, and it was a topical record. So it covered everything from gun control
到乔治·弗洛伊德事件，到新冠疫情，是一张内省的时事专辑，发行在新冠疫情的黑洞里，无法宣传，无法巡演。很高兴我能做出那张专辑。我为此感到非常骄傲。而这张专辑，在经历手术之后，以及这个创作过程——因为还没有完美的结局——是我在十年里第一次找到快乐。
to George Floyd to COVID to an introspective topical record released into a black hole of COVID that it couldn't promote, it couldn't tour. And it's good that I was able to do that. I was very proud of it. This record, post-surgery, and the process, because there's no happy ending yet, is that I'm finding joy for the first time in a decade.
我是说真正的快乐。我已经有十年没体会过快乐了。为什么，为什么？这就是因为嗓音。因为嗓音，是的。就在不久前，两三周前，在洛杉矶的那个“Music Cares”活动上，我受到了表彰。格莱美奖每年挑选一个人来表彰他们的音乐作品，
I'm truly finding joy. I haven't had joy in a decade. Why, why? And that's because of the voice. Because of the voice, yeah. I was honored just recently at this Music Cares event, two weeks ago, three weeks ago out in LA. The Grammys pick one person to celebrate their catalog,
对我的情况来说，主要是表彰慈善事业。迈克尔·麦克唐纳也参与其中。对。是的。而我，今年不是致敬对象。但在那个活动结束后的周六早晨，我醒来时心想：感觉有点不对劲。然后我想：我知道是什么了。
and in my case, the philanthropy. Michael McDonald's involved with that. Yeah. Yeah. And I was, this year's not an honoree. And on the Saturday morning after the night, I woke up and I was like, something's weird. And I went, I know what it is.
这是10年来，我脑海中唯一的那个声音是我自己的。没有怀疑，没有恐惧，没有多余的想法，你知道的，就是——昨晚我玩得很开心。尽管经历了，尽管经历了手术，你本可以……我在过去十年里把自己折磨得够呛。我把自己折磨得像个傻子。反正我每天都在这么做。
It's the first time in 10 years the only voice in my head was mine. No doubt, no fear, no second thoughts, you know, it's just, I had fun last night. Would you have, despite your, despite the surgery. I would have beat myself to shit for the last decade. I would have beat myself silly. I do it daily anyway.
而且我并不觉得这有什么不对。我不喜欢那样，肖恩。我他妈的受够了。告诉我你是怎么停止这么做的。什么，折磨自己吗？但你知道我总是怎么说的，我们不久前还在聊这个，如果折磨自己或者贬低自己能治愈你的话，
And I don't have anything wrong with that. I don't like that, Sean. I'm fucking tired of it. Tell me how you stopped doing it. What, beating yourself up? But you know what I always say, we were talking about this a while ago, if beating yourself up or putting yourself down,
那我们早就都被治好了，对吧？这根本不管用。就是不管用。很难停下脑海里那个声音，你可能是个完美主义者，所以只要达不到标准，你就会开始折磨自己。我每次参加完任何社交活动后都会折磨自己。我一上车就会想：
if that cured you, then we'd all be fixed, right? It doesn't work. It just doesn't work. It's hard to stop that voice in your head that you're probably a perfectionist, and so anything less than, you start beating yourself up. I always beat myself up when I leave any social event at all. I'll get in the car, I'll be like,
天哪，刚才那样可以吗？我是不是对那个人说了那样的话。我们管这叫“社交宿醉”。哦，社交宿醉，对，完全是这样。肖恩有次对我说，我记得，你说过：“没有人比我自己对更我严苛了。”我说：“那我可得试试。”
God, was that okay? And I said that to that person. Personality hangover, we call it. Oh, personality hangover, yeah, exactly. Sean said to me once, I remember, and you said, nobody's harder on me than myself. And I said, give me a shot. Yeah.
对。真的。但约翰，是什么原因——约翰，是什么导致你不断折磨自己，是因为你无法随心所欲地做你想做的事吗？你知道的，就像你只是……对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. That's true. But John, what was it, John, what was bringing on the beating yourself up just that you weren't having access to do your stuff? You know, like you were just. Yeah. Yeah.
这就好像，你知道的，我常说，我唯一进过我鼻子的东西就是我自己的手指，而现在上帝突然拿走了我的工具，我真是黔驴技穷了。那个疯狂的医生说：“我不知道这是怎么回事，但我刚刚把所有的信任都交给了你。”你什么意思，你不知道这是怎么回事？现在我漫无目的地流落街头。为此吃更多药吧，为此再打一针吧。肖恩能感同身受，对吧？
It was like, you know, I was saying that, you know, the only thing that's ever been up my nose is my finger, and now suddenly God's taking away my tools, and I'm at my wit's end. And the crazy doctor says, I don't know what it is, but I just gave you all my trust. What do you mean you don't know what it is? Now I'm aimlessly out there. Take more drugs for it. take another shot for it. Sean can relate, right?
然后我就陷入了这种状态。当我参演——不是最近的百老汇演出，而是我以前演过的另一部音乐剧。叫什么来着？《承诺，承诺》。哦。哦。
And I'm going down this. When I did, not the recent Broadway show, but I did another musical once. What was it called? Promises, Promises. Oh. Oh. Yeah, thanks.
对，谢谢。我连续一年都在服用泼尼松。对，对。就因为你的声带，一直发炎，一直发炎。那不是生活，那根本不是生活。而且它会让你发胖。而且会让你有点发胖。哦，杰森在那儿呢。
And I was on Prednisone for a year. Yep, yep. Just because you had a, it's always inflamed, always inflamed. It's no life, it's no life. And it gets you puffy. And it gets you a little puffy. Oh there's Jason.
我刚才还以为你的麦克风坏了呢。我们马上回来。SmartList受到Liquid IV的大力支持。所以，我以前也说过这个，但我每天醒来做的第一件事就是猛灌水。我狂灌水是因为这对身体真的很好。它能为你补充水分。而且，你知道的，我这么做不是为了……我是为了健康才这么做的。
I thought your mic was not working for a second. And we will be right back. SmartList is supported by Liquid IV. So I've talked about this before, but every day I wake up, the very first thing I do is is chug water. I chug it because it's really good for you. It makes you hydrated. And but, you know, I don't I don't do it for I do for my health.
我不是为了追求口感。但现在，当我在水中加入Liquid IV后，我居然开始喜欢上它的味道了。所以我喝得更慢了，因而更享受这个过程。我不再觉得这是一件每天早晨必须完成的苦差事。水流得很慢，我能品尝到每一口美妙的滋味。无论你是为了活着而补水，还是为了补水而活着，
I don't do it for the taste. But now when I use Liquid IV in the water, I actually enjoy the taste of it. So I drink it slower so it's more enjoyable. I don't feel like it's a chore that I have to accomplish every single morning. It goes down real slow and I get to taste every delicious sip. Whether you hydrate to live or live to hydrate,
Liquid IV为你解渴的速度比单喝水更快。它含有普通运动饮料三倍的电解质，外加八种支持日常健康的维生素和营养素。你所需要做的，就是拿上一根你最喜欢的无糖条状冲剂，兑上16盎司的水，你就在补水的康庄大道上了。你知道的，生活节奏太快了，我们有时会忘记停下来给自己补水。这真的挺重要的。但Liquid IV完美地解决了这个问题。尝尝看吧。无论你用什么方式补水，快去囤你的Liquid IV补水倍增器无糖版吧，
Liquid IV quenches your thirst faster than water alone. With three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink, plus eight vitamins and nutrients for everyday wellness. All you need to do is snag your favorite sugar-free stick and 16 ounces of water, and you're on your way to hydration. You know, life goes so fast we sometimes forget to stop and hydrate ourselves. It's really kind of a thing. But Liquid IV really takes care of that. Give it a taste. However you hydrate, grab your Liquid IV Hydration Multiplier Sugar-Free in bulk
全美Costco均有销售，或者访问liquidiv.com并在结账时使用代码smartless，首单即可享受8折优惠。访问liquidiv.com使用优惠码smartless，今天就开始更好的补水体验，首单即可享受8折优惠。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。所以伙计们，你们现在的社交电量还剩多少？我的社交电量是，我稍微有点耗尽了，但我还是会去做，因为我认为保持联系和社交很重要，不仅要和你的老朋友、家人保持联系，还要和刚刚认识的新朋友、家人保持联系。
nationwide at Costco, or get 20% off your first order when you go to liquidiv.com and use code smartless at checkout. That's 20% off your first order when you shop better hydration today using promo code smartless at liquidiv.com This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So guys, how's your social battery right now? My social battery is, I'm a tiny bit drained, but I still do it because I think it's important to stay connected and social with not only your old friends and family, but your new friends and family that you're just meeting now.
保持社交电量以保持大脑活跃是很重要的。但当电量有点耗尽时，也许正是时候讨论一下原因，以及你是否把精力分散得太广了。特别是经历了冬天的社交聚会高峰之后，对吧？对你来说，多少社交才算合适，你又是如何充电的呢？也许你在人群中充满活力，或者你更需要一些独处时间。心理治疗可以赋予你自我觉察能力，帮你建立一个不会耗尽你电量的社交生活。如果你在
It's important to keep the social battery going to keep our brains going. But when it gets a little drained, it's a good time to maybe talk about why and how much you're spreading yourself a little too thin. Especially with social gatherings picking up after the winter, right? What's the right amount of socializing for you and how do you recharge? Maybe you thrive around people or maybe you need some more alone time. Therapy can give you the self awareness to build a social life that doesn't drain your battery. If you're
考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行，旨在提供便捷、灵活且适合你日程的安排。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且随时可以免费更换治疗师。用BetterHelp找到你的社交甜蜜点。今天就访问BetterHelp.com斜杠SmartList，首单即可享受九折优惠。网址是BetterHelpHELP.com斜杠SmartList。也就是betterhelphelp.com斜杠smartless。
thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist, and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Find your social sweet spot with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartList today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. That's betterhelphelp.com slash smartless.
感谢Helix对SmartList的支持。所以，你知道的，我们都需要更好的睡眠卫生，对吧？因为当你睡足八小时或者尽可能多的时间时，第二天的工作效率就会高得多。你能完成更多工作，能更专注。所以除了睡觉和做其他事情（眨眼暗示）之外，你的床不应该用来做任何其他事，如果你懂我的意思的话。
Thanks to Helix for supporting smartless. So, you know, we all need better sleep hygiene, right? Because when you sleep the full eight hours or as many hours as you can, the next day is that much more productive. You can get more done, you can be more focused. So you're not supposed to use your bed for anything other than sleep and other things, wink wink, if you know what I mean.
所以我从不在床上看书，从不在床上回邮件，从不在床上工作。当我准备睡觉时，我看着那张Helix床垫，我知道自己将获得一生中最棒的睡眠。我不发邮件，我发“Z邮件”。懂了吗？Helix产品线提供20种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Luxe系列、最新发布的Helix Elite系列、专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童制作的床垫。在线购买床垫感到紧张？大可不必！
So I never read in bed, I never do emails, I never do work. When I'm ready for bed, I look at that Helix mattress and I know I'm going to get the best night's sleep of my life. And instead of emails, I do Z-Mails. Get it? The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses including award-winning Luxe Collection, the newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Nervous about buying a mattress online? Don't be!
他们的团队创建了一个Helix睡眠测试，帮助你在两分钟内找到最适合你的床垫。每个人都是独一无二的，每个人的睡眠方式也不同。这就是为什么Helix有几种不同的床垫型号可供选择，每一种都是为特定的睡眠姿势和触感偏好而设计的。在线订购你的Helix床垫，即可享受轻松的无接触配送。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单8折优惠以及两个免费枕头的福利。请访问helixsleep.com斜杠smartlis。网址是helixsleep.com斜杠smartlis。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。我是爱丽丝·莱文。
Their team created a Helix Sleep Quiz to help you find your perfect mattress in under two minutes. Everybody is unique and everyone sleeps differently. That's why Helix has several different mattress models to choose from, each designed for specific sleep positions and feel preferences. Order your Helix mattress online and receive easy, no-contact delivery. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartlis. That's helixsleep.com slash smartlis. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With Helix, better sleep starts now. I'm Alice Levine.
我是马特·福特。我们是英国丑闻的主持人。在我们的最新系列节目《希特勒的天使》中，我们讲述了声名狼藉的美女戴安娜·莫斯利的故事，她是一位英国贵族、米特福德姐妹之一，也是法西斯同情者。就像许多伟大的英国故事一样，它开始于一个奢华的花园派对。戴安娜遇到了风度翩翩的法西斯分子奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利。她被他的政治观点所吸引，但也被他极其英俊的外表所折服。这并不是一个传统的浪漫喜剧故事，但当她爱上莫斯利时，她正走在与家人、
And I'm Matt Ford. And we're the presenters of British Scandal. And in our latest series, Hitler's Angel, we tell the story of scandalous beauty Diana Mosley, British aristocrat, Mitford sister and fascist sympathizer. Like so many great British stories, it starts at a lavish garden party. Diana meets the dashing fascist Oswald Mosley. She's captivated by his politics but also by his very good looks. It's not a classic rom-com story, but when she falls in love with Mosley, she's on a
朋友乃至整个国家发生冲突的碰撞轨道上。不过，其中确实也有一些浪漫色彩。这对新人举行了一场由一位伟大的、未受赞誉的婚礼策划师——阿道夫·希特勒——精心策划的婚礼。所以与其说是《诺丁山》，不如说是《纽伦堡》。当英国与纳粹开战时，戴安娜不得不在爱情与背叛之间做出选择。这就是戴安娜·莫斯利从迷人的名媛到阶下囚的传奇旅程。在Wondery App或你获取播客的任何地方收听《英国丑闻》。现在，让我们回到节目中。约翰，当你无法进行表演、无法走出去大展身手时，那种沮丧感可能恰好伴随着，
collision course with her family, her friends and her whole country. There is some romance though. The couple tied the knot in a ceremony organised by a great, uncelebrated wedding planner, Adolf Hitler. So it's less Notting Hill, more Nuremberg. When Britain took on the Nazis, Diana had to choose between love or betrayal. This is the story of Diana Mosley on her journey from glamorous socialite to political prisoner. Listen to British Scandal on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. And now back to the show. John, with the frustration of not being able to perform and go out there and throw your fastball was probably at the same time that you were probably
你脑子里充满了高质量的点子和创作灵感。因为我发现，人越老就越聪明，做任何事都更拿手。所以你现在是不是在接近一个让它们完美契合的时刻，或者说，我希望如此。我觉得我快到了。我觉得我正处于那个边缘。
more loaded with quality ideas and inspiration for stuff to write. Just because I just find the older we get, the smarter we get, the better we are at everything. And so are you now sort of approaching a possible where they match or, you know, I'm hoping. I think I'm on the verge. I think I'm on the verge of that.
是的。过去这几张专辑我没能好好庆祝它们。我希望并且坚信，当我们能够再次出去巡演时，我将再次拥有那种机会。是的，这是我们的希望，真的。老实说，约翰，你这种态度，你拥有这种特质，你整个人都散发着积极向上的能量。
Yeah. These last couple of records that I couldn't fully celebrate these last couple of records. I'm hoping and believing that I'm gonna have that opportunity again when we do get to go out. Yeah, that's the hope, yeah. Honestly, John, that attitude, you have that, you kind of ooze positivity.
我得说，我之前没意识到你经历了这一切，但每次我见到你，你总是保持着这么棒的心态。你走进一个房间，带来光芒，询问别人过得怎么样。我很喜欢你这一点，我觉得这真的太棒了。而且我也知道你做了很多慈善事业，对吧？你创立了，你创办了“约翰·邦·乔维灵魂基金会”。
I will say, I didn't realize that you were going through all this, and anytime I see you, you've always got such a great attitude. You come into a room, you shine light, you ask people how they're doing. I love that about you, I think it's really great. And I also know you do a lot of philanthropy as well, right? You started, you got the John Bon Jovi Soul Foundation.
是叫这个吗？基金会和社区厨房，对。还有厨房。我是说，这太棒了。跟我们聊聊你做的事情吧。这几个家伙根本不知道这些事。太棒了。厨房？一千年前，20年前，我曾拥有过一支室内美式足球队。
Is that what it is? The foundation and the kitchens, yeah. And the kitchens. I mean, this is great. Talk to us a little bit about what you do. These guys don't know about this stuff. It's awesome. Kitchens? A thousand years ago, 20 years ago, I used to own an arena football team.
我的志向是有一天能拥有一个NFL（国家美式橄榄球联盟）球队，那是我在初试啼声。但为了在费城的社区里赢得民心，我说，我们必须比任何人都更有慈善心。所以那可以说是我的第一次尝试。我们开始寻找一个无论任何人、每个人都能产生共鸣的领域，那就是经济适用房和饥饿问题。于是我开始着手去做。当时每个人都说：太棒了，干得好。
My aspirations were to someday own an NFL team, and it was me cutting my teeth. But in order to win in the community in Philadelphia, I said, we got to be more philanthropic than everyone. So that sort of was my first foray into this. We started to find something that anyone, everyone could relate to, which was affordable housing and hunger. And so I started to do that. And everybody was like, yeah, bravo, good job.
仁人家园（Habitat for Humanity）每天都在做这种事。当2008年经济低迷来临时，多罗西亚说：“现在你得去喂饱你建的那些房子里的人了。”我当时想：嗯……顺着这个思路，她当场就为我们现在称之为JBJ灵魂厨房（JBJ Soul Kitchens）的项目制定了一个计划。简单来说，如果你们任何一个人来这里，
Habitat for Humanity does this every day. When the economic downturn of 2008 happened, Dorothea said, now you gotta feed the people in the houses you've built. I was like, hmm. And in stream of consciousness, she just lays out a plan for this thing that we now call the JBJ Soul Kitchens. Simply put, if any of you guys came
在桌上放30美元，这不仅能支付你自己的饭钱，还能支付另一个付不起饭钱的人的饭钱。这赋予了人们力量，因为我们会邀请那些付不起钱的人来做志愿者。如果你们来吃饭却不做志愿者，你可能会觉得你错过了派对，因为每个人都在花园里干活，或者在收拾桌子、洗盘子、叠餐巾。这不是什么重体力劳动，但当他们感到自己被赋予力量，并且通过劳动赢得了凭证，不仅能支付自己的饭餐，
and laid 30 bucks on the table, it would cover your meal and the meal of somebody else who can't afford to pay. It empowers people because we ask them if they can't pay anything to volunteer. And if you guys were to come and didn't volunteer, you'd sort of think you're missing the party because everybody's working in the garden or busing a table or washing a dish, folding napkins. It's not difficult labor, but when they feel empowered and they've earned the certificate to not only pay for their meal,
也许是个孩子，他带着全家人回来，那种作为一个十几岁的孩子把家人带回来并喂饱他们的骄傲感。这全都是从农场到餐桌的。我们不接受任何政府补贴。所以我们在一个改装成餐厅的汽车修理厂里开了第一家店。第二家店我们在新泽西州桑迪飓风之后建造，我们在周围提供各种服务，食品储藏室、食品银行、烹饪项目。然后第三家和第四家，这简直让大家大开眼界，开在大学校园里。
but perhaps it's a kid, he comes back with his entire family and he's got that pride in a teenager bringing his family back and feeding them. It's all farm to table. We take no government subsidies. So we did our first one in an auto body shop that we converted into this restaurant. Second one we built after Hurricane Sandy in New Jersey here and we have all this service providing around it, a food pantry, a food bank, culinary program. Then the third one and the fourth one, this blows people's minds, are on college campuses.
因为我们意识到——但大多数人觉得“等等，我刚把我孩子送进大学”。好吧，你猜怎么着？他们并不一定是因为喜欢才去吃方便面。他们根本没钱。所以我们在多年前就意识到了这一点，并在新泽西州的两个不同大学校园里各开了一家。
Because we were aware, but most people think, wait a minute, I just sent my kid to the university. Well guess what? They're not necessarily eating ramen by choice. They don't have any money. So we came to that realization many years ago, and we put one on two different university campuses here in New Jersey.
所以我们目前有四家这样的餐厅。然后由我自己或我们的基金会来资助差额。我们已经这样做了12、13年了。太酷了。我妈妈创办了一个，她是芝加哥地区为人们创办一个名为“伊利诺伊州北部食品银行”的创始成员之一。和你做的事情非常相似。
So we currently have four of those restaurants. And then myself or our foundation fund the shortfall. And we've been doing that for 12, 13 years now. That's so cool. My mom started a, she was one half who started a food bank for people in the Chicago area called Northern Illinois Food Bank. Very similar to what you're doing.
这也是她的传奇经历的一部分，人们至今仍铭记着她，这是“第二收获”组织的一部分，我确信你也……对，没错，我敢打赌这虽然让她辛苦，但也带给她巨大的快乐。不，威利，我想先说。所以她只是——她一直在关注、参与其中一部分——去吧，威利。我本来想说她可以把它命名为“关注饥饿”。
And that's kind of her legacy and she's still remembered there, it's part of Second Harvest, which I'm sure you. Yeah, right, and I bet you it gave her hard work but great joy. Well, no, Will, I wanna go first. So she's just sort of half, she's just kept an eye on, on part of, go ahead, Will. I was gonna say she could've called it Eye on Hunger.
肖恩的妈妈我们其实把它搬上了舞台，我们还举着它，对，眼睛，对。在他妈妈的眼睛里，我们举着它。对，真的。好人，好人，你们管他们叫朋友。等等，约翰，邦·乔维到底是个什么鬼？那是，那是什么国籍？邦·乔维到底是什么？这是什么问题？
Sean's mom We actually brought it out on stage and we held it yeah, eye, yeah. In his mom's eye, we held it. Yeah, for real. Nice guys, nice guys, you call them your friends. But wait, so John, what the hell's Bon Jovi? Is that, what nationality is that? What the hell is Bon Jovi? What kind of question is that?
搞什么鬼？肖恩，我能跟你谈谈吗？邦·乔维到底是什么？对。不，我是说……是意大利语，是意大利语。好吧，我从小到大一直以为那个名字是你自己瞎编的。B-O-N-G-I-O-V-I。
What the fuck? Sean, can I talk to you for a second? What the hell is Bon Jovi? Yeah. No, I mean, I... It's Italian, it's Italian. Okay, since I was a kid, I thought you made that name up. B-O-N-G-I-O-V-I.
B-O-N，同样的，G-I在意大利语发音中就是J的音。所以发音是一样的，只不过是用B-O-N-G-I代替了J。而且它一直都是两个独立的词吗？不，不，不。是愚蠢的美国人把它……用B-O-N-G-I代替了J。而且它一直都是两个独立的词？说实话，当我拿到唱片合约，把乐队凑在一起帮我录制《Runaway》的时候——因为当时这首歌在全国各地的广播里到处播放——我去找唱片公司说：“我们有个想法。应该是‘你’（You）。”然后我说：“如果改成‘我们’（We）怎么样？”
B-O-N, the same way, G-I, which in Italian phonetics is the J sound. So it's pronounced the same way, but it's B-O-N-G-I instead of a J. And it's always been two separate words? No, no, no. It's the silly American thatN-G-I instead of a J. And it's always been two separate words? And in truth, when I got the record deal and I had gotten the band together to help me play Runaway, because I had it on the radio all over the country, I went to the record company and said, we got an idea. It should be you. And I went, how about if it's we,
如果你还记得范海伦乐队，我的意思是，我们把它写成两个词。哦，很好。这很不错。哦，那太棒了。说实话，在80年代这么做确实有一点点这方面的原因，因为我不想当个独唱歌手。我真的很清楚那样压力太大了。
and if you remember Van Halen, I was like, we make it two words. Oh, very good. This is good. Oh, that's great. In truth, it was a little bit of that in the 80s because I didn't want to be a solo artist. I really knew that that's too much heat.
对，我是说，因为我小时候以为你们全都是亲戚。最糟糕的那种——最势利的泛泛之交会在街上走到你面前说：“嘿，邦。”嘿，不是“邦”，你这个混蛋。你算不上什么大粉丝。嘿，从音乐产业的商业角度来说，
Yeah, I mean, cause when I was a kid, I thought it was you guys were all related. The worst guy on the, that the worst fair weather fan will come up to you on the street and go, hey, Bon. Hey, it's not Bon, motherfucker. You're not a very big fan. Hey, on the music industry, business sort of,
而且因为我们的行业现在正在经历转型期，你们的商业模式更早地经历了转型。你觉得这个行业现在的表现和适应情况如何？你喜欢现状吗？我觉得我们至少已经达到了一个有稳定性的阶段。我以前就说过。
and because our industry's going through a bit of a transition now, your business started much earlier with the transition. How do you feel that the industry is doing and adapting? Are you a fan of the current state of things? I think we've at least hit a place now where there's stability. I've said it before.
我和我的乐队在那个时期以及与我们同期的那些人，经历过所谓的“淘金热”，你知道的，也就是CD被发明出来的时候，每个人都重新买了一遍自己的唱片收藏，你可以卖出2000万张专辑。所以我很幸运能处于那个热潮的中心。如今，因为他们终于在流媒体上尘埃落定，我对现状挺满意的。我希望——我怪苹果公司拆散了CD，
We, my band and I at this time and those around our period, were there for what was called the gold rush, you know, when CDs were invented and everybody bought their record collection again and you could sell 20 million copies of an album. So I was fortunate enough to have been in the heat of that. Nowadays, because they've finally settled on streaming, I'm okay with it. I wish and I blame Apple for breaking up the CD,
拆散了艺术品、那本书。他们一次只卖给你书中的一个章节，而不是整本书。我一直对此很不爽。他们的态度是：我们要一次只卖你一首歌，这样你就不用买整张专辑了。等等，我明明写了一整张专辑啊。我对整张专辑都很兴奋。
the work of art, the book. They sold you one chapter of the book at a time instead of the entire book. I was always pissed off about that. And their attitude was we're gonna sell you one song at a time so you don't have to buy the whole album. Well wait a minute, I just wrote the whole album. I'm excited about the whole album.
我想把它作为一个整体呈现出来。所以自从那以后，自从iPod问世以来，我一直都很不爽，但我认为我们在流媒体上已经达到了一个稳定的状态。在当前这种环境下，对于年轻才俊来说，令人胆怯的是，唱片公司现在不再因为你写了一首好歌而跟你签约了。他们想知道你在社交媒体上有多少点赞，
I wanna present it as a whole. So I've always been pissed off since that, the advent of the iPod, but I think we've reached a stable place with streaming. And in this current state of affairs for the young talent, what was also daunting was that the record companies now aren't signing you because you just wrote a great song. They wanna know how many likes you've got on social media,
这简直是个罪过。另一方面，这也为世界提供了一个再次诞生“鲍勃·迪伦”的机会，因为曾经有一段时间，除非你的唱片听起来像能在《美国偶像》上唱的那样，否则你根本拿不到唱片合约。所以互联网允许鲍勃·迪伦这样的人存在。流媒体带来了一定的稳定性，
which is a sin. On the other hand, it affords the world the opportunity to have another Bob Dylan because there was a period in time where unless you sounded like you could sing on American Idol, you weren't gonna get a record deal. So the internet allows for a Bob Dylan. The streaming allows for some stability,
尽管版税很低，但总归是有的。这就是新世界秩序。所以这就迫使你们这群人不得不出去进行大量巡演来赚大钱，而这其实挺让人精疲力竭的。它依然和以前一样残酷。对年轻乐队来说更艰难，如果他们没有唱片收入，或者没有巡演赞助以及我们40年前拥有的那些支持，他们该如何在路上养活自己呢？而现在他们不会再有这些了。
even though it's a low rate, but it's something. And this is the new world order. So it's obligating you guys to go out and do a bunch of touring in order to make a bunch of money and that's kind of exhausting. It's still as criminal as it ever was. It's harder on the young band and how are they gonna support themselves on the road
我听说过并参与过此类对话，但这显然不是我能直接感同身受的。对于初露头角的年轻人来说，这不再是一门大生意了。感觉就像是：我能去做这个，但我同时还必须得做这个和那个才能维持生计。
if they don't have any record money or there's tour support and all the things that we had 40 years ago that they're not gonna have now. I've heard and have been in on conversations, but it's obviously not something I can directly relate to. It's not as big a business for the young kid coming up. It's like, I get to do that, but I'm also gonna have to do this and this in order to make a living.
所有的娱乐行业都一样。感觉你必须学会包办一切。我经常思考这个问题，这就好像今天作为一个年轻演员出道，与我们刚出道时相比——那时你可以出门找工作，去试镜各种角色，参与其中，为试镜飞行员角色、拍电影而努力，
It's the same with all entertainment. It feels like you have to learn how to do it all. I think about all the time, it's like starting as a young actor today, as opposed to when we started out and you could go out and you get a job, you audition for stuff, you were in the mix, you auditioned for pilots, you get a movie,
但现在做这些太难了，因为如今一切都彻底乱套了。或者你拍个商业广告，拍完就能指望拿到3万美元的收入。而现在全都是非工会的了，对。对，你还可以拍个金格雷姆麦片（Golden Grahams）的广告。你知道我的意思吗？有人拍过金格雷姆的广告吗？我在里面开卡丁车呢。
but do all that, because now it's such a free-for-all. Or you could do a commercial and you could expect $30,000 by the time it's done its run. Like now it's all non-union and yeah. Yeah, you could do a Golden Grahams commercial. You know what I mean? Has anybody ever done a Golden Grahams commercial on that? I'm in a go-kart in that one.
我儿子是个年轻的有抱负的演员，他走进试镜房间时有一种魔力，但因为他是伴随着新冠疫情成长起来的，而且现在所有试镜都在Zoom上进行。我认为所有的选角导演都错过了年轻演员或演员们的个性，
My son is a young aspiring actor and he would have that magic when he walked into a room for an audition, but because he came up during COVID and now, everything is on these Zooms. And I think that all those casting agents are missing out on the personality of the young actor or actors coming in
他们错过了那些能赢得你芳心的特质，而不仅仅是照本宣科地念台词。不过我得告诉你，我目前正处于一个项目的选角阶段，这些选角试镜没有一个是线下的，全都在Zoom上进行，我甚至有点嫉妒这些演员不用经历对我来说永远是压力最大的事。
and winning your heart, not just reading their lines. I will tell you though, I'm in the middle of casting something right now, and none of these casting sessions are in person, they're all on Zoom, and I am so jealous that the actors are not stuck in what was always for me the most stressful thing I could ever do.
是的，这也是真的。就是坐在大厅里，听着前面的演员在试镜时表现惊艳，他们迟到了，而我一直在反复温习台词、温习台词，然后走进去，不得不跟他们进行那些废话社交，现在我满头大汗，不得不强行切换状态，然后我得开始表演，接着他们拿到——
Yeah, that's true too. Was waiting in the lobby, hearing the actor before me doing it, killing, them being late, me going over my sides and over my sides and then going in, having to do the bullshit talking with them and now I'm sweating and I'm having to be, and then I gotta switch into acting gear and then I gotta do, then they get,
那简直太折磨人了。事实上他们现在可以在Zoom上完成试镜，对我来说，这压力小多了。但我认为这里面一直存在一个缺陷，杰伊，因为你不应该把所有试镜同一个角色的演员都塞进同一个房间里。这只是……难道没有其他方式吗？比如按时间预约？
like it was so nerve wracking. The fact that they get to do it on Zoom now, to me is like, it's much less stressful. But I think there's always been a flaw in that, Jay, because you shouldn't just put all the actors up for the same role in one room. It's just, you know, is there another way to do it? Like schedule them?
整件事就是个折磨。对，全都是……我不知道，但经历过那种经历也有其独特价值，你知道的，作为一个在90年代的纽约度过20多岁、参加过上百万次试镜的人来说，是的，经历过无数次面试砸锅，我从那个过程中学到了太多。而且相反地，当我终于开始取得成功时，我真的非常感激。直到30多岁我才取得成功，我对此充满感激，因为我经历了那些
The whole thing is torture. Yeah, it's just all. I don't know, but there's something to also going through that experience, you know after as somebody who I Grew up in New York in the 90s in my 20s and went on a million auditions Yeah, and bombed a bunch and I learned so much from that process and then also Conversely when I did have start having success. I really appreciated it wasn't until my 30s that I had any success, and I really appreciated it because I had gone through that
漫长岁月的挣扎，曾经食不果腹，你知道的。我在这个过程中还交到了一些朋友，所以他们也错过了这一点。我交到了很多朋友。对吧。很多朋友。我只是觉得他们错过了展现个性的机会。是的，我同意，肖恩。
for so many years and was starving and you know. I also made some friends during the process, so they're missing out on that too. I made a lot of friends. Yeah, right. A lot of friends. I just think that they missed the personality. Yeah, I agree, Sean.
稍微讨好一下那个选角导演，让他们看到那种灵气。并且让他们知道你在片场会不会是个麻烦。他们是好人吗？是的。约翰，我觉得你完全说到点子上了。我觉得，我刚才也在想你之前关于专辑的那番话。
Wooing that casting agent some and letting them see that spark. And knowing whether they're gonna be a problem on set. Do they have, are they nice people? Yeah. John, I think that you're totally onto something. I think there, I was also just thinking about what you were saying before about albums
努力赢得选角导演的青睐，让他们看到你的火花。还要知道他们在片场会不会惹麻烦。他们人好不好？是的。约翰，我觉得你真的说到了点子上。我觉得，我刚才也在想你之前关于专辑的说法
and when you would write an album. And I was just thinking like, you remember that feeling, you really hit on something, that feeling as a kid of getting an album and taking it home and taking the plastic off it and taking the sleeve out and reading the lyrics and listening to every frickin' song. How does it start? And then the third song.
当你写一张专辑的时候。我当时就在想，你还记得那种感觉吗，那种小时候买一张专辑，拿回家拆开塑料膜，抽出歌词本，读着歌词，听着每一首该死的歌的感觉。它是怎么开始的？然后是第三首歌。
Is it my imagination or is the third song always one that kicks your ass? That's the single, right? That's the single. Okay, all right. Is that way, I didn't know that. Is that by design? It just happens to be, it's sort of commonplace.
是我产生幻觉了还是第三首歌总是那么震撼人心？那是主打歌对吧？那是主打歌。好吧，好吧。是这样的吗，我之前不知道。这是刻意安排的吗？刚好是这样，这算是一种惯例吧。
You kind of start slow and then you nail them and then yeah, and then there's a bounce. Living on a prayer was the third track on Super. Was it really? There you go. Hey, give me the first note. Are you by piano or a guitar or anything? Give me the first note of the chorus.
你一开始放慢节奏，然后惊艳所有人，接着，对，然后就会有一个高潮。《Living on a Prayer》就是《Slippery When Wet》专辑里的第三首歌。真的吗？你看。嘿，给我第一个音符。你旁边有钢琴、吉他什么的吗？给我副歌的第一个音符。
Sean, are you gonna sing? I'm gonna try it. Oh, oh please, thank you. Come on. Well, we're out of time everybody. I'm not that close. Now you are. Stay tuned for Smartless Extras, where you can enjoy some of Sean's...
肖恩，你要唱吗？我要试试。哦，哦拜托，谢谢。来吧。好吧，各位我们时间到了。我离得没那么近。现在是了。请继续收听Smartless Extras，在那里你可以欣赏到一些肖恩的...
It's that, D minor. We got it. Can you hear that? Yes. Can you hear that? Yes. I had to run across the room and bang on the piano. Wait, wait, wait. But you're not seated.
就是那个，D小调。我们找到了。你听得到吗？听得到。你听得到吗？听得到。我不得不跑过房间去弹钢琴。等等，等等，等等。但你没坐着。
Whoa, whoa. Is that the first note, but it's up in octave? Yeah, it's a G. Whoa, halfway there. Yeah. Go on. Whoa! Nope.
哇，哇。那是第一个音符，但高了一个八度？对，是个G。哇，已经完成一半了。对。继续。哇！不对。
It's so high. It's so high it's crazy. You know what you do then is you hold the microphone out. No. It's too high. Yeah. It's so high it's crazy. You know what you do then is you hold the microphone out. Oh! Just sounds like you're furious. Let the audience do it. You hold the mic over the audience and go,
太高了。高得太离谱了。你知道那时候该怎么做吗，就是把麦克风递出去。不。太高了。对。高得太离谱了。你知道那时候该怎么做吗，就是把麦克风递出去。哦！听起来你很生气。让观众来唱。你把麦克风对准观众然后说，
Buzzy you give dogs a bad name. But John, you know what? Whenever your songs come on the radio in the car, I will pretend I'm you and I will scream my head off. Love that. Oh yeah, it's impossible, impossible not to just absolutely belt out one of your songs, John, when they come on.
Buzzy，你给狗狗抹黑了。但是约翰，你知道吗？每当你的歌在车里的收音机里响起时，我就会假装我是你，然后拼命尖叫。太棒了。哦对，当你的歌响起时，约翰，真的不可能，绝对不可能不放声高歌。
I love that. It's just the best. Dude, we've taken up too much of your time already. You're such a- So much fun. You're the man. John, when you're coming to town, let's hang out. I would love that. Nothing would make me happy.
我太喜欢了。这简直太棒了。老兄，我们已经占用了你太多时间了。你真是个——太有趣了。你真够意思。约翰，你什么时候来我们这儿，一起聚聚。我太乐意了。没有什么比这更让我高兴的了。
You're never coming back. Very brave. Don't give me a number. No, let's do it in New York. Let's do it in New York. That would be great. That would be awesome. And then we'll do it,
你再也不会来了。非常勇敢。别给我一个数字。不，我们在纽约聚吧。我们在纽约聚。那就太棒了。那太棒了。然后我们再，
JB's in New York for the next six months. Let's do it. Yeah, please. Let's get together. Cool guys. This was really a joy. Thanks for doing it, John. Likewise, get together cool guys. I I was this was really a joy. Thanks Likewise, thank you. You're such a great dude. You're such a such a cool dude Yeah, and such a such a great artist and thank you for taking the time and wish you all the best man
JB在纽约待接下来的六个月。我们聚聚吧。对，求你了。我们聚聚吧。酷小伙们。这真的是一次享受。谢谢你参加，约翰。彼此彼此，聚聚吧酷小伙们。我，这真的是一次享受。谢谢，彼此彼此，谢谢你。你真是个大好人。你真的是个，真的是个很酷的对，而且真的是个非常伟大的艺术家，谢谢你抽出时间，祝你一切都好，老兄
Can't wait to see you again. Thanks guys. Thank you. All right. Have a good one. Bye now The great John Bon Jovi, he's great so fucking easy. They don't make them like that anymore You know, I mean great the great John Bon Jovi. He's great. So fucking easy. They don't make him like that anymore. You know? I mean, great, the great John Bon Jovi is just sounds like a little like we need a better word than great. Yeah. JB, you were just, yeah. Yeah, what do you, how do you, yeah, I just said the great John Bon Jovi, but you're right. It doesn't seem like it's enough. Right. Well, cause I mean, well, and who's doing it? What they did, who's doing that today? There isn't a size of a band today like that.
迫不及待想再见到你。谢谢你们。谢谢。好的。祝你们过得愉快。再见。伟大的约翰·邦·乔维，他太棒了，他妈的太轻松了。现在没人像他那样了，你知道我的意思吗？伟大的，伟大的约翰·邦·乔维。他太棒了。他妈的太轻松了。现在没人像他那样了，你知道吗？我的意思是，伟大的，伟大的约翰·邦·乔维听起来有点像我们需要一个比“伟大”更好的词。对。JB，你刚才，对。对，你，你怎么，对，我刚才说伟大的约翰·邦·乔维，但你是对的。这似乎还不够。对。嗯，因为我的意思是，还有谁在这么做？他们所做的，今天谁还在这么做？现在没有那么大阵仗的乐队了。
It's all sort of been diluted a bit. I didn't even ask him about the prep for a show with the hairspray and the hair and the outfits and the energy. Those were all wigs, all wigs. No, I'm kidding, I'm kidding. Yeah, that's a... No, super easy to hang out with. Yeah, he seems kidding. I'm kidding. Yeah, no, super easy to hang out with. Where did you meet him, Will?
这一切都被稀释了一点。我甚至没问他关于演唱会前喷发胶、弄发型、穿演出服以及保持体力的准备工作。那些全都是假发，全都是假发。不，开玩笑的，开玩笑的。对，那是个……不，和他在一起超级轻松。对，他看起来，开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。对，不，和他在一起超级轻松。你在哪里认识他的，威尔？
I met him, we have a bunch of mutual friends, and obviously- Long Island. And just, yeah, just over the years, and he is one of those guys, every time you see him, he's just, he's very sort of warm and very generous with people. Actually, one time I had lunch with him years ago. We were down on vacation and Archie was maybe a year old.
我认识他，我们有一群共同的朋友，很显然——在长岛。而且只是，对，这些年来，他就是那种人，每次你见到他，他总是，他非常热情，对人也非常慷慨。其实，多年前我和他吃过一次午餐。我们当时在度假，阿尔奇大概一岁左右。
Feels like this could be a St. Bart story. Go ahead. Yeah. We were down on vacation. And he got, Archie got like all these like little bites all over, we didn't know what was going on, we were freaking out, you know, you got a one year old, you're like, what's going on, we're in the middle of nowhere.
感觉这像是一个圣巴茨岛的故事。说吧。对。我们当时在度假。然后，阿尔奇全身长了好多这样的小红包，我们不知道是怎么回事，我们都快急疯了，你知道的，你有个一岁的小孩，你就会想，怎么了，我们身处荒郊野岭。
And John helped us sort of call a friend who had new, you know, got us in, you know, to get him looked at, it was great, he was very sweet. I love that. He's a very sweet guy. Yeah, he seems super cool. You know, that Slippery When Wet album was so huge, that's where that Living on a Prayer song was, but there was another song on there.
然后约翰帮我们联系了一个朋友，他懂得，你知道的，帮我们安排了，你知道的，让他去看了医生，太棒了，他人真的很好。我太喜欢了。他是个非常好的人。对，他看起来超级酷。你知道，那张《Slippery When Wet》专辑太火了，那首《Living on a Prayer》就在那张专辑里，但里面还有另一首歌。
Oh my God, here it goes. And it was called, and really it's a real song. Oh, I know, I know. I'm sorry, do you have another appointment? No, it's called Never Say Good Bye. It's a real song. Fuck it your nickname is shoehorn. Could you just try to shoehorn? You're always looking for a way out. We always got you SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
哦天哪，要来了。那首歌叫，而且这真的是一首歌。哦，我知道，我知道。对不起，你还有别的约会吗？不，那首歌叫《Never Say Good Bye》。这真的是一首歌。去你的，你的绰号叫鞋拔子。你就不能试着生硬地扯进来吗？你总是在找退路。我们总能抓住你。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. SmartL Less. If you like smart list, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wonder.com slash survey. Hello, I'm Johnny Knoxville.
SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔贾夫和贝内特·巴尔比科100%有机手工打造的。SmartLess。如果你喜欢SmartLess，现在就可以通过加入Wondry App或Apple Podcasts上的Wondry Plus提前收听无广告版。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上无广告收听。在你离开之前，请在wondery.com/survey填写简短问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。你好，我是约翰尼·诺克斯维尔。
And I'm Elna Baker and we have a new podcast that's called Pretty Sure I Can Fly. Yep, we've teamed up with my friends and bar mates from SmartList to create a podcast where we talk to folks who have more balls in a bowling alley. People who accomplish something extraordinary despite people telling them that it couldn't or shouldn't be done. You'll hear stories about the Air Force doctor who buckled into a 600 mile per hour rocket sled and became the fastest man on the planet. And a man who wrestles alligators and sharks for fun.
我是埃尔娜·贝克，我们有一个新播客叫做《我确信我能飞》。是的，我们和来自SmartLess的朋友兼酒吧酒友们合作，打造了一个播客，我们在节目中采访那些比保龄球馆里的球还要多的人。这些人取得了非凡的成就，尽管人们告诉他们这不可能或不应该去做。你会听到关于空军医生的故事，他把自己绑在时速600英里的火箭雪橇上，成为了地球上最快的人。还有一个为了好玩而与短吻鳄和鲨鱼搏斗的男人。
Do not do this. You'll hear about a foul-mouthed moonshiner. Got a two-inch dick and a six-inch tongue and knows how to use both of them. And an even more foul-mouthed female stunt pilot. We got bull riders. Balloonists. Bob Sletters. And big wave surfers.
千万别这么做。你会听到一个满口脏话的私酒贩子。长着两英寸的鸡雀和六英寸的舌头，而且知道怎么同时使用它们。还有一个嘴更脏的女性特技飞行员。我们有骑牛者。热气球飞行员。雪橇手。还有冲浪大咖。
People who lay their balls on an anvil and hand the other fellow the hammer. Okay, I bet you've actually done that, Johnny. Maybe for sweeps. Follow Pretty Sure I Can Fly on the Wondery app. Or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Pretty Sure I Can Fly early and ad free right now on Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那些把蛋蛋放在砧板上，把锤子交个另一个人的人。好吧，我打赌你其实已经做过那事了，约翰尼。也许是为了冲收视率。在Wondery App或任何你获取播客的地方关注《我确信我能飞》。你现在就可以在Wondery Plus上提前收听无广告版的《我确信我能飞》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。